Hello everybody!
Hello, hello!
Do I sound better now?
Guys, do I sound better now?
I don't know.
I dug through the grave of old PC-Kun and managed to find the old sound settings.
So I need to know if I'm better now.
If everything sounds better.
Oh my god.
Yes, but a bit loud.
Okay, let me adjust that real quick.
How do I do that?
Oh wait, I can turn this down to... there.
Is that better?
Is that better everybody?
Am I still loud?
I'm always loud.
Like, you telling me like, Doki, you're just a bit too loud.
That's just saying, Doki, stop breathing air.
I don't know.
Is Sound Guy here?
Guys, I'm just a mess.
Okay, you aren't loud.
Okay, good.
Okay, Sound Guy says I'm not loud, so I'll put it back to 100%.
Alright, nice.
Do I sound the same?
Sound Guy.
Do I sound like I sound like on PC-Kun?
May he rest in peace.
I now have a hotter younger voice.
I'm a younger version of you, but like, I still miss you.
Like, I'm not gonna forget the memories you've given me.
Oh my god.
It's been... it's been wild.
There's so many announcements.
So, if you guys didn't know, if you guys didn't follow...
I need like... there's so many announcements I need to make on...
I need to make on the community post on YouTube.
Because it's building up.
There's a lot of conventions.
A lot of world tour stuff for conventions.
Um... a lot of...
Uh... a lot of like, announcements.
A lot of merch coming out.
So if you guys didn't follow me on Twitter, uh...
Today, Hiya and IPP have announced, uh...
Uh, that I will be at Anime Expo.
Remember during the charity event thing?
Uh... where I was like, hey guys, I'm gonna be...
Um... I'm gonna be... I'm gonna be at the...
Anime Expo.
This is what it is.
I'll be at Anime Expo.
Um... at first it was originally like, you know, I'll just be there for July 4th to 6th.
Because that's when Anime Expo is gonna be.
And then they realized, wait, it's your birthday!
On July 4th!
Yes!
My real birthday.
For those who don't know, July 4th is my actual real birthday.
Because you're like, wait a minute Doki, didn't you celebrate your birthday like...
Like a couple of months?
No.
This is my real birthday.
So... so...
On July 4th, I will be celebrating my...
Uh... one of my five real birthdays.
Um... and uh...
Uh... IVP and Hyatt found out.
They're like, wait, July 4th is your real birthday!
I was like, yeah!
They go, yeah.
And then they're like, why don't we like...
Make the booth like decorated to a birthday theme for you!
Which was really sweet.
They didn't have to.
Like I was just gonna be there as a guest.
And stuff.
So like, it was really sweet of them to offer to do like a birthday theme for my booth.
Just for like the sake of it just being my birthday.
Because they were just gonna decorate it like Doki theme.
But because they found out it was also my birthday, they were like, we're gonna make it more like celebratory.
To celebrate your birthday and everything.
So it was really sweet!
So there's gonna be some announcements at the IVP slash Hyatt booth.
But don't worry, like some of these announcements will of course be posted on social media.
Regarding what it is.
Because we're gonna be announcing it at the booth.
And then like whatever the announcements are, we're gonna be posting it on social media.
I'll also be streaming on my birthday.
So...
So you don't have to worry about that.
I'll also be streaming on my birthday.
After...
Because after the...
I believe it'll be a panel on the 4th.
So after the panel, there will be a birthday stream as well.
For all the dragoons who won't be there.
Because it's gonna be treated like an anime convention.
Like panels and stuff like that.
So whatever I'm doing there is just like the usual.
Like what I usually do for conventions.
So like a panel, a karaoke, and a meet and greet.
So the only bonus is that during the panel though.
I'll be celebrating my birthday.
But I'll still have my regular birthday stream.
It's not like...
Oh, like Anime Expo is the birthday stream.
There will be a birthday stream after the Anime Expo panel.
That's hosted by...
That's hosted by ibp slash hyatt.
So look forward to that.
What else?
U2s!
My U2s figure is out now!
We've almost hit a thousand sales already!
Which is great news!
Thank you so much for supporting my very first figure!
I hope there will be many more to come.
I hope the success of this U2s figure might reflect on more potential collabs in the future.
So please feel free to check out the U2s figure.
And I believe my mod will post a link to it very soon.
It was really funny because like...
Okay, it's a little embarrassing.
Because apparently...
Hyatt and U2s were watching the stream.
So...
They were both watching the stream.
Because, you know, after the whole mess earlier...
Regarding, you know, the four Windows 11 keys.
So like, you know...
I finally activated Windows, by the way.
Because they...
Hyatt gave me like extra instructions on how to...
Like being like, oh, go to command.
And type these random magical letters.
And stuff.
And then... so then I did that.
And it worked!
So then... so then they replied.
Now you have three extra keys!
Smile!
This is what one of the Hyatt employees...
Or like IPP employees wrote to me.
It was supposed to be a secret!
So now I have three Windows 11 keys.
One of them which I paid $200 for.
Because I was panicking and freaking out.
Because I was like, I have a stream!
But I can't activate my Windows!
What if I just buy a Windows key myself?
Maybe that's the problem.
Maybe that's the issue.
I need to purchase my own Windows key.
And then... yeah.
It's okay.
It was $200 Canadian.
Okay, it's not...
It's not as okay.
But like...
At least it was $200 Canadian.
And not $200 American.
Anyway.
Also, YouTube was also watching the stream.
Because they were like...
Oh yeah!
They were like...
Did you like...
Give a shout out to the YouTube speaker.
Um...
They're like...
Oh!
I don't know.
Maybe you did a shout out to the YouTube speaker.
Because it launched yesterday.
Um...
What do you...
It's okay if you talk about it on like...
You know...
Today's stream.
And then later on they're like...
Never mind.
We saw that we sponsored your funeral.
So...
They're like...
Oh, never mind.
We saw that YouTube sponsored the funeral.
So you're good to go.
So...
Yay!
My sponsors watch my stream.
They found out that they like, you know...
They accidentally sponsored my PC conspiracy.
Ah ha ha!
This is what the YouTube person said.
I thought it was so funny.
This is what you wanted YouTube.
You got the money.
The best prime spot is like the Super Bowl.
It's like the Super Bowl chat, you know?
But like cheaper!
Anyone would want to sponsor your funeral.
Especially as high prolific as PC-kun chat.
Um, Albert, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Fahad, thank you for the super chat.
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
At the funny Doki figuring from YouTube's description for increased marketing.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, it's so... it's like... it's such a rare opportunity.
How many funerals are you able to legally sponsor, chat?
Just think about it, guys.
It's like prime real estate.
It's... it's... I honestly think it's like the next marketing genius move.
Because it's like... they're dead anyway.
And funerals are so expensive.
But all the family loved ones will be there.
Because they're like, oh, he's dead.
I... you know, I gotta pay my respect.
So it's like... and it's like different demographics too.
People from like different ages and demographics will be there.
And you gotta pay for a funeral.
So like, funeral caskets are not cheap.
And you gotta buy land for the grave too.
So like, imagine like, you know, you can grab a sponsor.
And then, you know, sponsored by Coca-Cola.
And then Coca-Cola gets a grave spot that's gonna be there for centuries.
Just think about that.
Like, you know, the gravestone with a Coca-Cola emblem on there.
Like, brought to you by Coca-Cola.
And a sponsored casket.
You can paint the casket red.
And like, you know, put the Coca-Cola logo on the top.
When you like, you know, after you close the lid on the...
You know, when you pay your respect, the lid's open.
And then you close the lid, there's the Coca-Cola logo there.
And everything.
And then the casket can be painted red.
And you don't have to pay anything because it'll be sponsored by Coca-Cola!
You know?
They're dead already!
And you can serve Coca-Cola at the funeral.
Like the... you know, like those funeral parties.
Okay, I wouldn't... I can't say party.
But...
It's not really... It's not really a party.
But like, you know, like the funeral...
Get-together with everybody.
Getting like... I'm going to hell.
I'm definitely going to hell with this idea.
The wake!
The wake chat!
The funeral service.
Um...
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't wait to have a DokiBird sponsored coffin and tombstone.
Wait, that's my...
Oh my god!
Anime!
Anime themed funerals!
Like, who wouldn't want to be buried with their own shit?
I need to stop cooking.
I'm sorry, capitalism's got me.
I need... I need to stop cooking.
JJK funeral coffin!
Oh my god!
Buried with your favorite anime.
I mean...
Copyright... It won't be copyright infringement if the company...
The copyright holders make merch out of it.
They just need to sell their likeness to other companies.
The funeral partners who would be like official partner with JJK.
Like, imagine a funeral parlor who's...
Literally says, official partner with JJK.
Like, imagine that.
That would be... That would make so much money.
Now...
JJ, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Partner with Briar's Ice Cream.
We get the money.
Cool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It would make so... Okay.
You guys might think my idea is ridiculous.
But you know...
Like, maybe in 30 or 40 years...
This will happen.
It might be dystopian now.
You might think it's dystopian now.
But I swear, it's gonna be a fucking money maker.
And like, in 30 to 40 years...
I am...
Like, if I stop streaming in 30 or 40 years...
But then I see the anime like...
I see anime themed funerals becoming real.
I'm gonna revive my dead channel.
Just to make a video and be like, I told you so.
And clip this exact moment.
And be like, nobody believe me.
I could be a millionaire.
I would have been a fucking millionaire.
But nobody believed in my ideas.
So I didn't have the confidence to sell my idea.
And make millions of dollars.
Because my chat didn't believe in me.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Razzy.
Can't wait to be lowered into my grave in my doki themed coffin.
While the Santa music plays.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I am a visionary.
I know where capitalism is going next.
But you guys didn't give me the confidence to take this to Shark Tank.
Um...
Shanino, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm imagining a waifu artwork on the casket cover.
Look, if people can marry Hatsune Miku, people can be buried with Hatsune Miku.
Think about it.
Sharko, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
At my funeral, can I just have your laugh in the background?
As my coffin gets lowered into the crown.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Anyway.
Okay, sound gap here says I am louder.
Okay, I lowered myself.
Is it better now or should I lower myself a little bit more?
That sounds like a threat.
What?
It's like till death do us part.
Well, like, they had the...
Why can't they get buried with Hatsune Miku?
I don't understand.
And then they can play like Hatsune Miku, like World is Mine or something.
Um, for the funeral song.
Alright, let's actually play Train.
Sorry.
Sorry, this was like a...
This was a weird tangent to get into before Train Simulator.
But here we are.
Train Simulator.
It's not showing up on the screen for some reason.
Let me make sure it shows up.
Oh my god.
Is this one of those things where it can't be game captured?
I swear to God.
Is this a game that can't be game captured chat?
Oh.
Oh my god.
Alright, let me double check.
It could be.
It could be one of those games.
Uh...
No?
Alright.
Okay.
Academy.
Probably the train should have left 18 minutes ago.
Please.
Please show up on the screen.
I just wanna play video.
Oh, there it is.
Alright, nice.
Alright, it's up.
Alright, guys.
I should totally do this.
Alright, I'm already overwhelmed with how like all of this works.
Apparently, it's like just like flight simulator where, uh, where, you know, it's super, it's a very accurate simulator to like driving a train.
So, I'm already a bit overwhelmed.
But I do have the flight simulator experience.
So, I should be able to take the things I learned from flight simulator into train simulator.
Because like how hard can driving a train be?
You can literally only go forwards and backwards.
Like there's, you're on a track.
You're not on anything else.
You're literally on a railroad track.
So, like how bad can it be?
Uh, Dr. Cranberry, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you.
Here's to the $15,000 train simulator DLC.
But gotta collect them all.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, I forgot to put on a hat.
Give me a sec, guys.
I gotta disappear for a little bit.
I forgot.
I forgot to put on my hat, guys.
I bought a hat just for this.
Okay, give me a sec.
How do I do this again?
I'm a professional.
Okay.
Hat.
Oh, there it is.
There's my hat.
Okay.
Nice.
I have a hat, guys.
Oh, shit.
Where did my hat go?
Okay, I need to be smaller for this hat, though.
God damn it.
All right, there you go.
All right.
It looks a little dumb.
Wait, maybe I should just...
Wait, I got an idea.
Okay, you can't see this yet.
You must be like, Doki, what's going on?
We don't know what's happening.
It's okay.
It's...
Trust the process.
All right, there you go.
Did it work?
Wait, it's not even attached to me.
Okay, there we go.
Yes.
All right, don't worry.
Don't worry.
It's almost done, guys.
It's almost done.
It's a little tiny, but like it's not about the size of the hat, chat.
There we go.
Hat,
guys.
Everywhere I put it looks so stupid.
This is okay.
Okay, maybe like it's a hat on top of a hat.
I don't know.
Maybe that's it.
There we go.
There you go.
It's a hat on top of a hat.
That should be better, right?
Maybe a little bit bigger?
There we go.
Yeah.
Does that work?
This is...
I should...
Oh, wait.
You're right.
Guys, give me a sec.
Whoever said that.
You're a goddamn genius.
You're fucking right, guys.
Give me a sec.
I have a better idea.
Guys, I'm cooking right now.
Give me a sec.
Okay, there we go.
Oh my god, alright.
Alright.
Let's go.
Hello.
Your conductor is here.
Your train conductor is here.
But like, okay, the problem, the issue right now is that, am I tall enough to reach the controls?
That's the issue right now.
I hope I'll be tall enough to reach the controls today.
A little bit lower?
Okay, don't worry sound guy, I got you.
Let me check where my sound is at.
I got you guys.
23 minutes and we're not playing the game yet.
This truly is the Doki Bird experience.
Get a box to stand on?
Wait, you're so right.
You're so right.
Give me a sec.
Give me a sec guys.
Let me box PNG.
Let me grab a box right now to stand on so I can reach the controls.
Before we go.
Before we do anything.
Guys, this is very important chat.
Like, we gotta be sure that I can reach the controls guys.
We have to be sure about this.
Alright, save image.
Alright, save it.
That's a WebMVP?
What?
How am I gonna stand on the box if I don't have a box PNG?
Alright, we're gonna grab this random Canadian box.
Cause it's transparent.
Oh my god.
It's a WebP file?
No!
It's a fake PNG!
Guys, we're gonna start the stream soon chat.
This is very... I need to be able to see the controls guys.
Do you guys want me to crash?
I need to be able to see the controls!
Alright, is this free?
Is this a real PNG or a fake PNG?
This is... God damn it.
I hate the fake PNG.
Please.
All my homies.
Hate the fake PNGs.
Is this real or fake?
We're gonna find out.
Oh, it's a real PNG.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
Okay.
I'll put it here.
And then... guys, I ordered a shipment from Amazon and got a box.
So I can do this gag.
There you go.
I got my... I got my little baby booster.
Alright, academy.
Whoops.
Okay.
I don't know what any of these trains are.
There's too many trains.
There's like $1500,000 worth of trains.
What?
I don't know.
Okay.
I wanna ride the steam train!
So I can be like Choo Choo.
Let's use the coal.
Let's destroy the environment with the coal.
Uh, detective, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Soon when?
Soon this month or soon this year.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I wanna... I wanna ride a steam train and use the coal.
Alright, let's see.
Is that it?
Coal for the coal gods.
Yes.
Alright, here we go.
This should be good.
Oh my god, that's me!
That's me!
That's how I envisioned myself as.
Oh my god!
It's beautiful!
Charcoal as well?
Oh my god, that's great.
Welcome back to the cab of the BR-4F steam locomotive.
There's more to this train than simply starting.
And stopping.
Wait, B?
I need my controller?
Oh god.
Alright guys, I thought I could just handle this with mouse and keyboard.
Alright, let me plug in my controller.
Okay.
Oh fuck.
I forgot like...
This PC I need to bend all the way down.
And plug stuff in.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, I'm ready.
How do I do this?
How do I...
Whoa.
Am I going?
Yeah!
Wait, is that it?
Wait, driving a train is so easy!
Is that it?
Do I just...
What am I doing?
Lee!
Is that it?
All you have to do is press all these buttons?
There's no more buttons to...
Oh!
I can put my hand...
I reached the fuck...
Wow.
I reached the...
I reached the flat destination.
Oh my god, this is so easy!
Wait!
Anybody can be a conductor!
Okay, alright.
I think we're ready for the real deal.
That's all I needed to know.
That's literally...
That's...
Oh wait, you guys can't hear the game?
Oh, whoops!
I don't know if the game was quiet or you guys couldn't hear it.
Let me check the output real fast.
Guys...
Okay, let's see.
System...
Guys, I told you guys.
My whole sound system is a mess right now.
So...
Oh shit!
Alright.
Let's see.
System...
There we go.
Now you should be able to hear it.
Alright.
I think from that...
I think from that, we've like...
accomplished everything we need to accomplish.
Uh, we're guiding like driving trains.
So, is there another steam?
I wanna drive another steam train.
Wait, what's that rail fad?
Someone...
Who made this?
Wait, any steam trains?
How do I find steam?
Okay, steam...
I wanna use coal.
How do I...
Do you want a bullet train?
No, but I wanna use coal.
Coal and charcoal.
What's the point?
What's the point if I can't use coal trains?
This game only has one?
Guys, I need to buy a steam train.
Guys...
Alright.
Oh, wait!
That's a steam!
Blue Peter!
That has to be steam!
Right?
That looks like charcoal.
She wants to ruin the...
Damn right.
I'm glad you understand.
Alright.
We're gonna...
We're gonna drive the...
The...
The Blue Peter.
And then...
Let's see.
We'll start.
I think that's it, right?
Blue Peter.
Like I said, what's the worst that could happen?
Alright.
Here we go.
What's the worst that can happen, chat?
Hello, driver.
You're in control for the final leg through to Holly Head.
Prepare your local...
Oh my god.
I learned this.
Go.
Why is it not going?
Go faster.
Hello.
Goodbye, lady.
Goodbye.
Bye.
Choo choo train is going forward.
We've done it.
We've done it, guys!
We've done it, Dragonz.
Driving a train.
We did it!
Let's look at the other side of the window.
Oh my God.
Where's my train?
Oh my God!
Yes!
Air Pollution!
I'm just joking.
I'm not actually cheering on the Polluted Air.
Oh my.
Oh my god, that is a lot of smoke.
Guys, I'm only joking guys.
I'm not actually cheering it on.
There's a brake?
Where's the brake?
I don't know what any of these buttons do.
Oh wait, is it this?
100?
What is that?
Oh, that has to be the brake, right?
And maybe we'll do 58.
And then...
Oh, Kimmy brought down.
Don't worry, I got you.
Wheel slip?
Oh my god.
Is it this?
What did my wheel slip?
Guys, did I broke my wheel?
Did my wheel die?
Legacy realistic driving mode?
Legacy mode selected?
What did I select?
Okay.
Alright, let me bring down the volume.
Sorry for like...
Sorry for like getting you out of the immersion guys.
I need to fix the audio.
You can't adjust the audio?
In your main...
What?
What do you mean I can't adjust the audio?
Yeah.
What do you mean?
Why can't I adjust the audio?
Sorry guys.
Sorry.
Sorry for the...
Lack of immersion just now.
We'll be back.
Alright, we'll be back with the train services soon.
Alright here we are.
I lowered it.
Oh shit!
Alright, there we are.
Did I?
Wheeeee!
Weee!
Wheeeeeeeee!
What is this?
Load and unload?
Wait, what is this?
What's this?
Lights?
Oh, let's turn on all the lights.
What's this?
Emergency brake?
Oh shit, sorry!
Sorry!
No, stop!
Don't brake!
We're going through the tunnels!
I didn't mean to do the emergency brake!
Don't worry, we're burning more coal!
More coal!
It's okay, we might have stopped.
But the coal engine is going off!
It's okay, I killed the engine?
No, I'm still walking!
Guys, it's okay, I'm still moving forward.
I'm just making sure I'm burning all the smoke.
I'm making sure the environment knows I'm coming in.
The wind might be losing coal resources, but don't worry, my job here is done!
Choo choo!
Oh my god, I'm upside down!
I'm rolling in coal!
Yeah!
It's okay, if any passengers come, I'll be there.
If any passengers are sticking their heads out right now and breathing in all that smoke that's coming out of the train, do not worry.
Your insurance does not cover this.
I'm sorry!
Wait, can I collide into another train?
Oh my god, is that possible?
Does any train wanna... Sorry, I have to tab out.
I'm sorry for the immersion.
I have to adjust the volume.
Wait, what happened to my game?
What happened to my game?
Oh my game is freaking out.
Wait, it is possible?
Oh my god.
There it is.
The smoke is like a balloon, if you think about it.
You can run out of coal?
There's no way you can run out of coal.
I own this train.
There's no way.
Where the rails go?
Right there.
I own the rails.
There's no way.
Look at it go!
My beautiful train!
Where?
Where does it say my coal is running out?
I see nothing that says that.
What do I know when I arrive?
This is a long train ride.
Faster?
How do I go faster?
Do I put more coal in?
Wait, A?
What's this?
I put more smoke in.
Do I...
Can I actually go faster?
Put more coal in it!
Somebody, shovel more coal!
Alright, lower the volume a little bit more.
Woo!
Somebody!
All I'm saying is that, like, I should own the entire coal... the entire coal industry.
Yay!
How am I running out of water?
There's water right here.
There's no way I can stop my train and grab the water at the lake.
How can I run out of water?
This is bad.
The water's low?
How do you know the water's low?
Is it that blue thing right here?
Guys, I think the blue thing right here is my water.
Okay, alright, I stopped the coal shoveling.
Oh, I ran... whoops.
Guys, guys, why didn't you guys stop me?
Guys!
Why didn't you guys brought more water?
Did I fail?
I... I can fail?
Wait... what?
Oh, wheel slip.
O.P.
error.
Wheel slip!
Guys, what the fuck does wheel slip even mean?
I don't know about this.
If I don't know what error I made, how do I actually made an error?
Like, what?
How could I have made an error if I don't even know what the error is?
That's what I'm saying.
If I don't know what my error is, then like, how do you know I failed?
Chat.
How would you know?
Alright, what's a better train?
That was a bad train.
It wasn't a bad conductor.
It was just a terrible train.
Uh...
Hahaha!
I... There's no... There's no way I could just run out of water.
There was literally a lake next to me.
Like, how could I run out of water when there was a lake next to me?
It was not a conductor issue.
Alright, what's a better train?
That train was just garbage.
Hahaha!
Recommend me your best trains, chat.
Give me your best trains.
Classic blame.
It's not a human error because I'm not human.
You can't say that, guys.
And if you blame me, then you just hate tomatoes.
Uh, welcome to the...
Hahaha!
Uh...
Welcome... I bet you're a vegetarian if you're blaming me.
You fucking veggie eater.
Hahaha!
Rasidazzi!
Welcome to the Dokey uh... train...
Doki track train line.
Whatever you need to do...
Wherever you need to go, we may or may not get there.
Rasidazzi!
Thank you!
You're the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
God damn eating-eating my people.
Alright.
Let's see...
What's a better train, guys?
A bullet train?
Aren't those the kind of trains that go really fast?
Fast.
Oh, I like those.
My game crashed.
I thought I thought we wouldn't have these issues.
This must be I think this is an actual game issue.
There's no way.
I can't.
Alright.
Let's go pick.
Okay, people said the bullet train.
Alright, high speed.
Is this a bullet train?
Is that bullet train?
The high speed train?
There's no... Okay, at least like it was super boot up fast.
Is that the bullet train?
Is your new name wheels... I don't even know what wheelslip is.
Is that a good thing?
Haki, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, that's a bullet train?
Okay, this time we'll retry this.
I can't run out of water.
I can't run out of water for this one because it's not like coal related.
It's a bullet train.
It's electricity.
So like where does the water go?
Alright.
Hello, driver.
Just taking over from another driver.
So please open up your door and sub a train ahead of a departure at Drizdan.
Have fun.
How do I open my doors?
What is this?
Load and unload?
Sander?
Uh, lights?
Wipers?
What's sander?
How do I open my door?
2D map?
Task log?
Uh, couple?
Oh!
Couple?
What do I do here?
Do I take these trains off?
Guys, I think I should have...
I think I should have went to train school.
Guys.
I think...
I think I should have went to train school, guys.
Oh!
I can come onto the train!
Guys!
Get on!
Get on the train, everybody!
What's the coupling?
What happens if I decouple it?
Oh, is this like...
Oh, I guess I'm just gonna decouple it because that's what it was before.
Are you guys on the train, guys?
Are you guys on the train now?
I can't tell.
I can't tell if you're on the train or not.
Guys.
Guys, get on!
Guys, come on!
Why does nobody wanna...
Why does nobody wanna get on the train?
Guys!
I don't understand!
There's nobody that wants to sit on my train!
I don't need you guys.
I'll just go straight.
Timeless.
Timeliness.
Bonus.
Oh!
Alright.
Choo-choo!
Guys, is anybody else on the train with me?
Guys?
Why does nobody here wanna sit on the train?
Come on!
I'm a first...
I might be a first time conductor, but I'm a first time train.
But I know what I'm doing.
Yay!
Tickets!
Anybody got some tickets?
Tickets, guys!
Beep-beep!
Look!
Oh my god, there's like wipers too.
I can wipe my train.
Guys!
I don't understand, guys.
What is this?
Guys, we're turning on the lights!
Wait, what have I...
What does this even do?
It doesn't even turn it off.
Okay.
Four lights.
Nice knowing dragons.
There's like zero people on this train except for me.
Like, it feels like people don't trust me and I don't know why.
Like...
Oh my god, that's a lot of trains.
Wait, what have I...
Can I detect something?
Can I detach from the other trains?
Is that possible?
Pick up passengers from...
Oh, I can pick up passengers?
Guys, when do I get there?
I arrived at 1731.
Oh, I'm speeding?
It's okay.
It's not like I'm gonna crash or anything.
It's a bullet train!
I should be speeding.
What do I do?
Deduct more points and revoke my license?
Faster!
I can't do jack shit!
Wait, I'm gonna make it.
Wait.
Is that where I'm supposed to go?
Guys, is this where I'm supposed to go?
For like my stop?
Okay.
Is that it?
Is that my first stop?
That has to be my first stop, right?
I think I passed it.
Did I pass it?
Where's my first stop?
I can't read the map, guys.
Oh, 400.
Oh!
Oh, okay.
It's 400.
Okay, we go faster.
Uh, I'm not there.
Guys, yell at me when I'm there.
We'll go back to fast then.
Not for...
Oh!
Oh, what the heck happened?
Oh, I accidentally tapped to the next...
Oh, shit.
Accidentally tapped to the...
Accidentally tapped to the next window.
My mouse...
My mouse went to the next window.
Alright, that's okay.
That's okay.
We're still...
We're still on it.
We're still on the train.
Wait!
I can detach?
Can I det...
What's this?
Can I detach from...
From my other trains?
When my other trains are detached?
What does this do?
I don't know what I did.
I pieced some stuff together.
I don't know.
I think it'll be fine, right?
I don't know what this does.
But like...
As a train enthusiast...
Wait, no point.
Oh, okay.
I don't know what it does.
But like...
Oh, there it is!
Oh, shit!
Why did you guys...
There's the sub!
No!
I told you guys to tell me!
I told you guys to tell me when I need to stop!
Guys!
Why didn't you tell me to stop?
No!
Where's my train?
Where am I?
Oh, there I am.
Alright, that's fine.
We'll like go backwards.
We'll go backwards.
It's fine.
Emergency brakes...
We can go backwards, right?
Alright, go backwards.
Go backwards.
We gotta pick people up.
Alright, there you go.
My power coins!
Don't worry, I'm coming there!
Wait, I'm not even there?!
Wait, I didn't even miss it?!
But what's that station?
Okay, platform 8.
Where's platform 8?
Hey!
This is not platform A?
Oh!
This is platform 2!
JK!
We're going back forward!
I meant platform A, guys!
Sorry!
I went the wrong way.
Forward!
Oh shit!
I didn't go forward!
Sorry!
For any passengers...
Oh shit!
There are passengers!
Dragoon 1!
I told you!
I knew it!
I knew my dragoons believed in me!
I knew there were believers!
Who believed in...
Who believed in my dragoons... Oh look!
There's other dragoons!
I see you!
Am I still going backwards?
This is not good.
Okay, I need a break.
I need a foley break.
I think.
I knew!
I knew it!
I knew you guys!
Trust me!
I knew it!
I knew I'm not a disappointment!
Okay.
And now we go this way.
Beep!
See?
I knew it, guys!
I knew you guys would ride on my train!
What is this?
Emergency brake... engine start.
Look!
Isn't it beautiful?
It's like we're on that train together, chat.
You and I.
All aboard.
Dark, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I knew not going to train school was a good idea and was a scam.
I knew train school was a scam all along.
You have passed the signal at danger.
Game over.
What the fu-
Gutter.
What the fu- What the fu- What are you us  Oh my god!
Oooohhh whoaoh-o-o-o-ohh I thought speeding was baaaaaad Guys Why did nobody worry me about my speeding my drive quality I was just trying to look at the scene.
That was just a bad train.
That was also a bad train, chat.
Like how was I supposed to like learn if like I'm given like all these bad trains and like I'm failing because the trains were just not good.
These trains were just terrible trains.
Trains.
Tutorial.
I learned the controls.
What is there to teach me?
We're going off the rails on this crazy train.
Media, thank you.
Super chat, thank you.
Like what else would they need to teach me?
Polargus.
Thank you.
Super chat, thank you.
You know the devs of a simulator are sissies when they don't show the explosions or collisions.
Thank you.
Super chat, thank you.
Oh!
This has no rules?
I love no rules.
Okay, that's great.
Guys, no rules time.
How do I?
Okay, these are all my trains.
What's a better train?
Multi-level cab car.
Oh my god, double...
Double the victim.
Yes!
Okay, and then...
Wait, why is there two?
Why would we need two trains?
Oh, Washington to Baltimore.
Alright.
There you go.
That's the real.
Start.
Say it, what do you mean say it again?
More, more people on the train.
Isn't that what we want guys?
More people on the train?
Alright!
Get on the train!
Guys, get on the train guys.
It's loading time.
Get on, I see you guys slowly walking in.
Come on guys!
Walk on the train!
Why are you all just standing there?
Come on!
Guys, come on, dragons!
Hurry up!
We don't have all day, dragons!
We have plenty of room here!
Thank you for the five gift ships!
Thank you!
Come on guys!
Come on!
It's double!
Double!
It says, double the fun!
Wait, did I... did I press the wrong button?
Okay, wait, no.
Unload load?
Why is it not opening?
Open the doors.
Are people getting on now?
I can't tell.
Are people loading in?
I can't tell if people are going in or not.
Be not... be not afraid!
Oh, there it is!
The doors are opening!
The doors are opening over here!
Oh my god, it has an American flag!
Alright, here we go.
This is start... forward...
Train is about to start, everybody!
Oh my god, look how many...
This train is packed!
They fell...
Stop at Washington Union.
Station track.
Where is that?
Okay, guys, yell at me when I'm getting close.
To Washington Union Station Track.
Alright, guys, look, I need you guys to yell at me when I'm close to there.
Okay?
Oh shit, my brake is still on.
Alright, nice.
There's no rules to stop us!
Now nothing can stop us!
Alright.
Okay, let's sit with all the other people.
Oh shit, it's raining!
I should like... do the wipers.
There you go.
Whoa, that's a lot of controls.
Whoa!
What does this do?
What is this control?
I put the bell on, but what does the bell do?
I don't like that the lights started flashing.
Oh, horn!
Beep!
Oh!
I can't flip those?
Pussies!
Wait, where's my co-pilot?
Where's my co-train?
Wait, what's this?
I acknowledge you.
What does that do?
Okay.
I think all of these...
What's this?
Oh, this has to be like...
Oh, okay.
We gotta go full speed ahead.
This has to be like...
Oh, that's the release brake?
Wait, what's this?
What am I doing?
What is that?
What's that sound?
Guys, I don't know what that sound is.
I heard a sound, but...
I don't know what that does.
Oh, that's the brake!
Oh!
Alright.
There we go.
What do you mean aviation disaster?
That fucking plane was Jesus!
That was no disaster.
I think we're gonna be fine.
Let's sit with the people.
Let's let the conductor sit with the people.
Hey guys, you guys having a good time?
Whoa.
Oh my god, look at how fast we're going, guys.
Are you...
Hey, you guys heard of that movie?
Like, Train to Busan?
Good things always happens on trains.
It was like so popular and everything.
And like, it has to be a really good movie about trains then.
If that movie did really well.
Also, that other movie about trains where like...
Like, every population and citizen.
Like...
Um...
You know...
Wait, are we going?
Wait, why did we stop?
What's going on on the train?
Oh, I actually stopped.
Guys, sorry.
Sorry, the conductor accidentally stopped it.
Because like, she's not at the conductor seat right now.
But don't worry, we're gonna be...
Don't worry, everything will be fine.
Local break, no breaks.
We don't need breaks.
Wait, why aren't we going forward?
Alright, sorry.
I'm gonna be back with the train.
Like, I'm sorry, I have to do my job again.
Are we...
Wait.
What's going on?
Start.
Start the engine.
Did we run out of power?
Did we...
Guys.
What happened?
Did I hit something?
There's no way.
Where's the train?
Did I hit something?
Go forward.
Why aren't you going forward?
Somebody.
Help, the train stopped going forward.
I had...
The brakes are off.
What do you mean?
Okay.
Okay, I got this.
I got this.
Maybe it's this.
It has to be.
Is this causing the whole issue?
Is this causing everything?
Why is it negative?
No.
We have to accelerate.
And then...
Go.
Guys.
Wait for it.
Guys, we're on a schedule.
My train boss is not going to be happy about this.
We're not moving.
Okay.
Stay calm.
You won't get fired.
It's your first day.
No, how did I break it?
I just pressed buttons.
What if I put more sander in it?
I don't know what sander is.
But I'll put more sander in it.
Is that coal?
Put more coal in there.
Do I have gas?
Okay, I have zero power.
But like, that should be okay, right?
Oh no.
But like, how do I have zero power when the wipers are working?
Is it on?
Did I turn the engines off?
Guys!
Any train conductors?
Any...
Where are the train conductors?
Guys!
Train conductors, I need help!
Pull over down.
Oh, down?
Okay.
There.
Pull over is down.
And then what?
Yellow button?
What does the yellow button even do?
I just acknowledged.
Red stick?
Okay.
Alright.
Zero.
Release.
Release!
Blew up?
Blew up!
Go train!
Go!
Wait!
Is my train going?
Am I moving?
I'm moving!
It was the yellow button!
I don't know what it was, but I acknowledged it and then it like, stopped working.
I don't know what this is.
It was the yellow button.
We're back online!
Nice.
Okay, I knew it.
Was that the brakes?
Oh, that's the brakes?
Why is it called acknowledge?
I thought it just wanted me to acknowledge it.
Why was it the yellow button?
Alright, nice.
We're back on schedule, guys.
Alright, back with the people.
Hey, guys!
So, like, we had a little...
We had a little issue with the train.
But, like, everything will be okay, dragoons.
Don't worry.
I know what I was doing.
A dead man switch?
Yeah, Dr. Cranberry, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The yellow button allows the train to know you care about it and you love it.
Yeah, that's what I thought!
I thought... because it was like, do you want to appreciate the train?
And I was like, yeah, I appreciate the train.
Like...
I don't know what dead man switch is.
It just says acknowledge.
And I was like, okay, I acknowledge your existence.
Like, how else was I supposed to know that it's supposed to... it's like, gonna stop my train?
I don't have a co-pilot with me.
I'm lonely.
I'm so lonely.
Wait, we're so slow.
Who the fuck end up... who stopped my train?
Who stopped my train?
Oh, no.
Wait, why did it stop again?
Did I acknowledge something again?
Who stopped it?
I left it unattended so it stops?
But I want to be with the people!
I did...
I don't think I did that.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Go forward!
Go!
Move!
Okay.
We'll put that down here.
Beep, beep.
Is it the bell?
Maybe I should stop having the bell off.
Or like, no, the bell should be on.
Guys, I stopped moving again.
I stopped...
Guys, I don't understand.
Why did I stop?
No...
I...
I acknowledge you.
Did it work?
Okay.
Maybe if I turn it on and off.
Maybe...
Okay.
There we go.
I push the button on...
The blue lever.
Okay.
Here we go.
I'm putting it at zero.
Zero.
And then...
Boom.
Oh, it's moving again!
Oh no, that's just the rain.
That's just the rain, guys.
Okay, maybe... Okay, keep everything at zero.
And we're resetting everything, guys.
Okay.
Zero.
I hope there's no train behind me.
Because that would be awkward.
Alright.
We'll reset it real fast.
Okay.
Hey guys, so we're gonna have a little delay.
We're gonna... We...
There's like a deer crossing in front of our train right now.
So like, because I am such a humanitarian...
And I don't wanna, you know...
Have bad karma.
We're gonna let some deers cross through the train tracks.
And like, behind the deers, there's also some geese as well.
And a little family of geese in front of us as well.
And that is why I delay.
And obviously, like, if you guys want me to go forward...
Then you want me to commit animal slaughter.
And you're not that bad of a type of people, dragoons, right?
So that's why we're gonna experience some...
Uh...
Some really, really...
Very tiny delay, guys.
Just very tiny.
So I hope you all, you guys, understand.
Alright.
I think they believed it.
Okay.
Alright.
That should be enough time, right?
We go forward.
Guys, I don't understand.
Guys...
Hahaha!
Guys, I don't understand.
Why isn't my...
Why isn't my train going forward?
Train should just go forward!
Maybe turn the brake on and off again?
Is this the brake?
Yeah, that's the brake.
Okay.
On...
I don't know what this is.
But...
On...
And then...
Off.
Is that it?
Am I going forward?
No?
What is this?
Locomotive brake...
Is it this?
I only have one...
Engaged?
I have more than one engine?
Oh!
What's this?
Go up.
Pull it back.
All right.
I pulled it back.
Don't worry.
We know what we're doing, guys.
Are we going forward?
Are we...
Guys.
I think we needed the tutorial.
Wait.
What does this button do?
Oh, it does nothing.
Okay.
It says emergency.
You had the locomotive.
Here we go.
We're going forward!
Guys!
Oh my...
I don't need squat.
Guys, I fucking knew it!
I don't need train school!
Anybody can be a conductor!
There's like five buttons!
Chat!
Alright, see?
Alright.
Hey passengers, luckily, we were lucky enough that the herd of deers and geese made it through!
So we can, you know, we can get started everybody!
We can keep on going to your destination!
We're not delayed, I'm pretty sure.
Where are we?
Alright, where is the stop?
We have to stop at track 9.
I think we're making good progress.
That's our train!
That's our train right there.
We're making really good progress.
We're not late, it just says stop at.
It didn't say what time.
It did not say what time.
I should be there.
Oh, so yeah!
Guys.
We're making really good progress, chat.
I'm sorry to all the actual train enthusiasts that are watching me drive this train right now.
Because I know it's making you feel...
How are we stopping again?!
Who keeps stopping our train?!
Who is it?!
Who keeps stopping?!
Who is doing that?!
I don't understand!
How am I hitting the brakes?!
Oh, I'm so sorry.
Whoops.
It was me.
I'm hitting the brakes.
Guys.
It was me.
I was the one that was hitting the brakes.
Oh no, I don't know how to start the train again.
I touched the lever again, guys.
It was me all along.
I keep stopping the train, chat.
Who would have thought?
It was me all along.
Every time you leave the train, the train alone, he gets sad.
All the train enthusiasts in my chat yelling at me right now.
Oh my god.
I keep forgetting how to start back the train.
Guys.
There should be a key that lets you start the train.
It just kick starts it.
There should be a key for that.
Like a hotkey.
Where I just press it and all the train will go fast.
Logico, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Dell, thank you for the super chat.
I can see the headlines now.
Tomato causes double decker train derailment in Baltimore.
Oh, there's another train!
Say hi to the train sister!
Hello, train sister.
How can he drive his train so fast and I can't?
What's the difference between his train and my train?
I don't understand.
Woodman, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I sent you an email about this game.
I'm actually a locomotive engineer and would love to help you out.
Alright, what do I do, Woodman?
What do I do now?
Why is my train always so clingy?
What buttons do I press?
Why is my train such a clingy little bitch?
Easy, don't break.
But I'm not going forward!
Guys!
I'm not going!
Maybe... oh, wait, wait.
I need to unlock it.
Did I unlock it?
Am I going forward?
Oh, I pressed the yellow again!
I pressed the yellow button!
I did it!
It's okay.
I don't need it.
We did it.
Guys, I did it.
I need to remember to not hit this button.
Oh my god!
And there's light now!
I'm doing a good job so the game is giving me light!
Guys, I'm doing a good job!
Yay!
Celebratory honk!
Honk, honk!
Honk!
No one needs a train, but I'm so lonely!
It's just me and the train!
I want to hang out with the dragoons in the passenger seats!
They're playing like Uno right now!
I need to press the button?
Why would I need to press the button?
Every time I press the button, I stop.
Oh, there's cars outside!
Hello, cars!
Where are the other trains?
Where are the other trains in front of me?
There's safety penalties?
There's no safety procedure!
What if I own the train?
If I own the railroad company?
Because railroad companies are a monopoly.
And it's my turn to drive the train?
I should have zero safety penalties.
I bought the game!
So I own this railroad.
Mr. Brokenbottom, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
This train reminds me of the train from the Sonic Murder Mystery Game.
Such clingy trains.
Thank you Mr. Oh shit!
It went yellow again!
No!
No, I got the safety penalty!
Stop!
I went over the safety...
I can't believe the safety police is here!
Every time I go too fast, the safety police stop me!
What a fucking loser!
No fun!
This train won't let me have fun!
They keep pressing the yellow button on me!
Every time!
Every fucking time!
And you hit control D and then control F.
I can get rid of the safety procedures.
That's good.
We don't need safety here.
We don't need safety...
I can't believe it!
They keep fucking getting me into the safety zone!
Losers!
Goddamn losers!
Boom.
There we go.
I pressed all the buttons again.
Let me drive my train!
We don't need safety!
What is this?
Signal speed.
Track speed.
I can't believe I can't do...
I can't do like...
Full speed ahead.
That's bullshit.
Bro, I'm not even close to my stop.
Every time!
Every fucking time!
Okay.
Release the brakes!
Release!
Go!
Alright.
Let's see.
Can't believe it!
Fine!
We won't go all the way.
We'll do 55.
Are you happy, train?
I even let you do 55!
55!
You know what?
You don't deserve win wipers!
You don't deserve it!
Yellow then breaks down.
Yellow.
Breaks down.
Alright.
Go!
Am I going forward?
Am I...
Wait, brakes are still on?
How?
Is this releasing it?
Local brake.
Train brake.
Alright.
Zero.
Go!
Oh, no.
Come on!
I turned it off!
Oh, I have to stop accelerating before I start?
Whoops.
Okay.
Maybe that's it.
Is that it?
Pull both red.
I think I pulled the red already.
Yeah, the red's already down.
Ugh.
All the way down.
Okay.
Are we doing it?
Guys!
You...
You decide to ride on the train instead of taking a car.
That's on you!
You know what you're getting!
Oh, my God!
He decided to ride a train.
That's on you!
Oh, my God.
The train police stopped me.
I can't believe...
The train police stopped me!
Fucking train police.
Don't get me laid to work.
You know who's driving this train!
You could've taken a plane or a car, and then, all of a sudden, this train has stopped A car!
Or a metro!
You could take any other train.
It's not new for riding on my train.
You know it was my first day.
Alright, let's see.
I'm trying to... the fucking fun police stopped my train like four times, okay?
And I still don't know how to fix this.
Okay, everything is off.
I pressed the yellow button.
The yellow button is pressed.
Is this off?
Yeah, this is off.
Alright.
And then...
There you go.
Can I go forward now?
This is not fair!
Forward!
Stupid rules and regulations.
Wait, is that another train behind me?
No.
Okay, I thought there was another train behind me.
That would have been awkward.
No, there's me.
There's me.
Do you guys see me?
There's me over there.
I keep turning the brakes on.
Is this the brakes?
Guys, I should have... Okay, after I head to the destination, I'm gonna go look at the tutorial.
I'm gonna look at the tutorial.
I swear.
I'll look at the tutorial.
I just wanna get to my destination.
Guys, why won't they let me go?
Hahaha.
I don't understand why the train would do this.
Alright, here we go.
Um...
Okay.
Let's see.
Alright.
Red handle up.
Yellow button.
Throttle off.
What's throttle?
Throttle.
Is this throttle?
Power controller.
Acknowledge.
Boom.
That's it.
Nobody's making it to their destination.
Nope.
Hahaha.
That's it.
Nobody's gonna arrive to their destination.
We're going back to train school.
We're going...
Hahaha.
That's looking it.
You guys all say, I'm fucking taking a taxi and going back to train school.
You guys can all call an Uber.
I need to figure this out.
Alright.
Driving.
Okay.
Let's see.
Which one was the train I was trying?
Alright.
Switching cabs.
Stop.
Okay.
Switching junction.
Loading passengers?
Should it just be this?
Alright.
Alright, guys.
Okay.
Welcome to the rail.
Complete each section after closing these messages.
And let's learn about switching junctions.
Modern busy railroads are controlled by...
Remotely by a signaling center dispatcher.
In freight yards, many small and frequent...
Uh...
Are required.
Making automatic control impractical in yards.
Those switches are manual?
The difference between the two types of switches can be identified by their...
Equipment.
A manual switch has a lever to turn it one way or the other.
An automatic switch has a small box containing...
Oh my god!
Manual junctions can be operated by clicking the lever or pressing G.
They can also be changed on the action...
What the fuck?
Up ahead, the pass switch is to the left.
Using the free camera, fly over and click on the lever?
I have to fucking get off my train and click on the lever?
What do you...
What do you mean?
What do you mean I have to click on the lever?
That's fucked up!
Wait, we should go forward?
Okay.
It's fine, we're going forward right now, right?
It's fine.
Oh, I have a co-pilot!
Guys, it's okay, I have a co-pilot.
Co-pilot!
That's gonna help me!
It's gonna help me, guys!
It's okay!
Wait, where's the lever?
Where's the lever?
Oh, here!
Oh god, guys!
I missed the lever.
Guys, it's okay, I pressed it now!
I did it!
Guys, it worked, guys.
Guys, I think I did it.
I reached it!
It said I reached it!
Guys, it said I reached it, so I assume I did it correctly.
Oh, I can like learn how to load an unknown.
Alright, guys, we reached our de- Okay, this is when we pretend we reached our destination.
Hello, everybody!
We reached our destination!
Welcome back!
We learned how to pick up passengers!
Oh yeah, I'm familiar on how to stop.
We're approaching the station.
Bring the train to stop alongside.
Okay.
There we go.
Are we slowing down?
Wait, are we there yet?
Oh shit, okay, guys, sorry.
We're gonna have to keep going.
Whoops, we sort of stopped a little bit.
Sorry, guys.
The train is experiencing a small delay.
Sorry, I stopped a little bit too early.
Don't worry, we're going back!
See, there's me!
We're starting again!
Don't worry, guys.
I know how to do this for real.
It's okay.
Sorry, I didn't realize where the train stop was.
Oh my god, there's people there!
There's people that believes in the Doki train!
They heard...
They heard I was gonna be here!
Wait, stop.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, I'm still in, I'm still in.
Sorry, this is a little...
I'm still in, guys.
See?
They heard!
Allow passengers on board.
Switch to external view and click on the button.
Click on the path form or press T.
Oh, wait, I was supposed to...
Oh!
I was definitely not boarding people.
Oh my...
Guys...
I was definitely not letting people in my train in the beginning, guys.
I just realized.
The people in my train from before were just trapped in there.
The people that were in the other train was definitely just trapped in there from a previous ride.
I definitely took them somewhere that they were not supposed to be.
Alright, we...
We learned!
Guys, we're learning!
We're learning!
Uh...
Objectives...
Okay, we don't need to know these.
So, we don't have water, so controls.
Alright!
Primary control...
What?
Electric, right?
No.
What were some of the actual good trains?
Okay.
Has to be like...
This one.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, we're gonna learn the controls, guys!
Back to train school we go!
This is a cab of a class.
The camera will change view if each control is set correctly.
Okay.
You need the direction power.
Direction is controlled by the reverser.
Push this all the way forward.
This train has combined power and brake levers.
Sat in the middle, power is neutral.
To start, pull the lever 2 or 2 to 3.
3.
That's 57.
Oh, I should not put it on 100 then.
Yay!
Oh my god, there's safety!
There's a safety thing behind me.
Is that safe?
Oh, it's not safe!
Oh, shit.
Yay!
Put it all the way.
Max it up!
I don't know what that yellow button did, but I pressed it.
I still don't know what it does.
I think I'm doing a pretty good job.
It says full power.
Hey, it told me to put full power, guys.
The main speed, we don't need any power because push the lever to off.
Every system may have a low setting may be required.
Off?
That's so fun.
How would my dragones have fun?
How would they have fun if the power is off?
They'll think it's boring.
Oh my gosh, they won't let me look at the passenger.
They won't even let me...
I want to stop.
Push the lever slowly forward until the camera resets.
Close this message box.
What?
Slowly forward until it resets.
Oh, all the way up?
Oh, okay.
I can't interact with the passengers.
It won't let me.
It's like they knew what I did in 19...
1975.
Okay.
Alright.
Nice.
Wait, that's so easy.
Wait.
All of this is so easy.
So like...
Did I learn enough?
What else do I have to learn?
What else do I have to learn, chat?
I don't understand.
Try the other train?
But I learned everything.
I learned everything though.
What else do I need to learn?
Driving again?
Wait, where's driving?
Driving.
What do you mean?
It's switching junctions and switching cabs.
We don't need to know that.
We already know how to...
Okay, I think we're fine.
Alright.
As long as there's no safety, we're fine.
Okay, quick drive.
Okay.
Custom.
I can...
Can I create my own train?
Oh my god.
I can create my own train.
Bro, this is where all the fucking nerds go.
I just do that?
Alright.
No engine found.
Where the fuck is an engine?
I don't know.
There.
Add to front.
It's incompatible?
It's just...
No engine.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh, it's wet.
Oh, wagon.
Diesel.
Electric.
Okay.
Maybe we can just add this.
There you go.
Name.
Dragoons.
Save.
Alright.
Where did my dragoon car go?
I don't know.
Where is it?
I created a dragoon car.
I can't believe it.
Oh, there it is.
Nice.
Alright.
Let's start.
No rain.
That shit sucked.
That shit fucking sucked.
Wait.
Free roam.
If I do free roam, does that mean like...
Wait.
Can I actually...
No, I can't.
Oh, I can't.
Oh, I don't have...
I don't have the...
It's only the en...
The engine is all...
Oh, you're right.
You're right.
We need like...
We need people in it.
Alright.
How do we add people into our train?
Okay.
Is that the wagon?
I want to add people to our train.
I need you guys to sit in my train.
Okay.
Add...
No.
Add back.
Delete.
It's incompatible?
How?
I want people on my train.
Wait.
That must be it.
No?
How is it incompatible?
Okay.
Guys.
Guys, I might...
Guys, I don't know if you guys noticed this, but I might not be...
I might not be a train expert.
Guys, is it noticeable?
Guys, is it noticeable that I don't know what I'm doing?
Can you tell, guys?
Can you guys tell?
Oh, okay.
Add to the front.
Oh, there we go!
What if I want to add a different part of this car?
Okay, insert.
Oh, alright, there we go.
There we go.
This is it.
We got it.
Okay.
Next.
This is the better Dragoons.
Alright, here we go.
We did it!
We have a new Dragoon car!
Alright, and then...
Alright.
Alright, we have like... passengers.
For passengers.
No, I want like...
You're right!
I should add more carts.
Oh my god.
You're right, guys.
Wait, you're so right.
Guys, we're going back.
We're going back.
We're adding more carts into this.
You're right.
Whoever gave me that idea, you're a genius.
More people should be on my train.
Alright, let's see.
Cabin, passenger car.
Insert.
Oh, it doesn't work.
Oh, it has to be an electric.
Okay.
Motor car.
Is that right?
Add to the back.
Ooh.
And then we'll have...
What's this?
We need more passenger seatings.
Okay.
Add to the back.
No!
Wrong one!
Add to the back.
How about this?
Is there like... cat... or is there a way...
Oh, okay.
No, that's just the regular stuff.
Alright, let's just keep adding.
How many can I add?
Alright.
We can keep going.
Can I make a really long car?
Can I just make it super long?
I think I can.
Add to the back.
Alright, nice.
There's no problems.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I'll keep adding more.
I mean, there's no problems with it.
Alright, nice.
For all you 700,000 dragoons!
Of course!
Nice.
Alright, here we go.
I think we're good now.
I think we can do this.
How many wag... I don't even know.
I just kept pressing buttons.
That's been my entire gameplay.
I just keep pressing...
Oh, it's still going.
Hahaha!
Guys, it's too long.
Guys, I think... I think it's too long.
Okay, okay.
We gotta... We gotta fix the train.
Okay.
No fun!
Guys.
Okay.
Let's start...
Let's start deleting.
Guys, what's the...
What's the maximum amount that I can add?
Alright.
Okay, maybe that's better?
Is this better now?
Train gods!
It spawned off the tracks.
Alright.
Now!
It should work!
Yay!
Alright.
Here we go.
Train gods.
Is this better now?
I can't believe it!
Dragoons!
You gotta stop derailing the train!
Hahaha!
I don't think it's my fault.
I think the dra...
It was just too many Dragoons on the train that it got derailed.
I think that's it.
There's no way.
Hahaha!
Bruh!
How can it be like derailing?
It's like...
Four!
Okay, there we go.
One, two, three, four.
Alright.
Four passengers!
That should be enough!
Alright, there we go.
Okay, now we can go on the train.
The long goon is too long.
There we go.
I like how it won't even let me see the train anymore.
I'm just looking at the top of the roof.
I can't believe it!
Why?!
Why do I keep derailing?
There's been trains that were that long?!
It's not even that long anymore!
It's literally three trains!
Guys, this is a scam.
It's literally four trains long!
How is that?
Too long!
Okay, there we go.
Longest train is almost... Yeah!
Like, it's not even that bad!
Can I see the roof now?
Oh, okay.
Now I can.
Alright, at least there's no...
Guys, there's no more derailments, guys.
I made it.
I didn't... I did not derail.
Oh, hey!
Alright, guys!
Guys, all aboard!
All aboard!
Get on my train!
Come on, this guy looks like he's having fun!
Look at the excitement on this guy!
No, no, we're not closing.
Come on, come on guys, come on.
Come on, I don't care.
As many passengers in as possible, guys.
There's no timer.
Come on, I know you guys want to!
All aboard!
No, no, no, we're not closing the doors!
Come on, sir, I know you want to get on this train.
Dragoons, I know you want to get on.
Oh, look, they're getting on!
All right.
No, no, no, don't worry, don't worry, red shirt guy!
There you go, don't worry, I got you, red shirt guy.
I got you guys!
All right.
Now we start the train.
Okay, I learned.
It was like...
this after this.
50 and then boom.
There we go.
Why don't we start it?
Oh.
There we go.
We did it!
Wait, what's the horn for this?
Oh, it's like the switch!
Where do we have to go?
Let's see.
Let's look at our map.
We need to stop at LAMSEC.
Where are we?
LAMSEC 2.
Where's our ride?
We're all the way here.
So, I mean, that's a particularly long ride.
Can't be that bad.
All right.
Okay, I think there's no more safety precautions, so we're fine.
Right?
Let's make sure there's no safety.
Let's...
I think we'll be fine.
Stick our head out.
Look at that!
Guys, we're doing so well this time.
Oh, shit.
How do I get closer?
That's not what I want.
No!
My train is moving away!
No train!
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
Nice.
All right.
I just wanted to, like, ride with the people.
Look at you guys.
I see you guys over there.
I see you guys.
Whoa.
You guys having fun?
Are you guys...
Oh, my God.
There's a full family in there.
Are you guys having fun, family?
What about over here?
Nobody here?
Where are the people?
Oh, look!
Another family!
Hey, guys!
Oh, no.
Never mind.
She's alone.
Wait.
There's birds, too!
I think I'm doing a great job.
Now that I'm not going full speed ahead, nobody can stop me.
You know what?
I'm feeling so wild.
Look!
And then there's me!
There's me!
I'm right here!
Guys, that's me!
On my train skin suit!
You know, driving a train ain't that hard.
Don't know why people were freaking out earlier about it.
Okay.
I'm over here.
And we have to stop all the way over here?
No.
Wait.
Where's Lamsac?
Where's Lamsac 2?
Wait a minute.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
It's all the way here.
And I am...
Where again?
Oh, shit!
We're almost there!
Watch the...
Another train's not gonna hit us, guys!
We're fine!
No other train's gonna hit us!
We're so safe!
Chat!
All the train training has saved us for this occasion, guys.
Our train training has led us to this.
We went to school for it.
So we'll be fine.
I can't believe someone's... I can't believe people buy DLC for this.
I can't believe people buy DLC for this.
Sorry.
Like, how different is the DLC?
How different is the DLC?
Like, between trains?
Because, like, I bought the deluxe version.
Because I wanted more trains.
But, like, you wouldn't pick a train in Joy.
With that patch, there's no way I passed it.
I guess if, like, the train is, like, particularly interesting, I can see that.
No, I didn't pass it.
Where is it, though?
It's, like, right...
Oh, it's right here.
I didn't pass it.
I'm, like, so not even close to it, I think.
Wait.
Yeah, no, I'm not close to it.
At all.
It just adds more trains.
But do they just...
Do they look particularly different?
I mean, to be fair, I feel like...
Okay, not gonna lie.
I feel like this...
Buying train DLCs for this...
Is cheaper than owning, like, those, like, mini trains.
You know those train sets?
Oh, wait.
No, I can understand now.
Train enthusiasts go fucking hard.
Like, the train collect...
I watched Young Sheldon.
So...
Sorry.
That's, like, sort of my point of reference.
But, like, I watched Young Sheldon and he's, like, a train collector.
So...
So, like...
So, like, I...
I can...
I remember...
And then I remember back in the day...
Back...
It's a good show!
You can...
Okay, Big Bad Theory, that was, like, you know...
Eh.
But, like...
But, like, Young Sheldon is actually really decent.
Okay?
You guys just laugh because you've never watched Young Sheldon.
You've never watched Young Sheldon so you don't understand.
Okay?
So, it's a good show.
It's just, like, a family!
It's, like, a family wholesome show!
It's not always about Sheldon.
Guys.
There's other characters in Young Sheldon.
Anyway!
Anyway, I know, like, train...
Train enthusiasts go, like, super hardcore.
But, like...
I...
So, like, I know, like, there's, like, train conventions, too.
So, like, you know...
There's, like, anime conventions.
There's, like...
Oh, I'm almost there!
I'm almost there guys!
I feel like I'm dying.
I wonder if zoomers are feeling... you know how some interests are considered for not the young?
So, except for young Sheldon.
But...
So I do wonder if there's enough new blood to replace the audience, the consumer base for trained collectors.
Because I know there's like...
I don't really see much about it anymore like I do in the past.
We're almost there!
Oh my god!
We're gonna get to our first destination guys!
It's happening!
Chat!
We're gonna get to our first destination!
Oh my god, we're almost there!
Oh my god!
We can slow down!
We're getting good at this game!
Wait, where's my train?
Guys, I don't know why I'm slowing down in time.
Guys, I don't...
Guys, I'm a little worried.
I'm not slowing down.
I'm not slowing down enough.
Guys, I'm a little worried.
Guys, I think we're gonna miss our stop.
Guys, I'm...
Guys, I'm not slowing down.
Guys, I'm a little...
I'm a little worried.
Guys, I'm not slowing down!
The station is ahead of me!
Nooooo!
Oh, I reached it!
I did it!
Okay.
Yeah!
We did it, chat!
We did it!
Never punished!
Woo!
Yippee!
Guys, we did it!
Guys, we stopped at our destination!
Chat.
We're such good.
And the game crashed.
I think it's the game.
Wait!
Okay, alright, alright.
We'll do one more.
Suggest me a train DLC.
Suggest me a train DLC, guys.
It has $15,000 worth of trains.
Should I get guys for the train sim?
That's what I'm saying!
I'm saying this has to be cheaper than the train sets and stuff.
So now I sort of understand why there's so many DLCs.
Because if you wanted to just own one of the trains, you can just...
I am not!
This is literally train simulator 2024!
What are you talking about?
How is there more?
I mean, there's train sim world.
I haven't played it.
There's train sim world.
There's train...
What the fuck is train Siberian?
Railway simulator.
Wait, I should have played this game.
What the fuck?
Wait, what?
What the fuck is this?
Alright guys, we're gonna like...
I'm gonna buy this right now.
I'm gonna buy train Siberian.
Alright guys, we're go...
You thought the ride was over.
But there's a surprise game.
There's a surprise game.
Oh my...
I saw...
Wait, it released like...
On 30th May.
I literally saw this game while looking up train DLCs.
But like guys...
New game alert guys.
Give me a sec guys.
I'm installing it.
Don't worry guys.
Guys, I checked the...
It is 24 gigabytes.
This cannot be well optimized.
I refuse to believe this game is.
Surprise.
Surprise second game.
Guys, we're gonna be playing something called...
Trans-Siberian Railway Simulator.
I saw 10 seconds of the gameplay footage where I shot...
Shoot a bear.
And then I was like...
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Then I got curious.
I got curious.
Trains and guns?
Oh my god.
Okay, we're gonna...
We have a little delay here.
It still has to do with trains though.
Don't worry.
Trains are still involved.
Alright, before that.
Let's go back to the other train DLC.
Train Simulator Classic.
What kind of trains are your favorite?
My train enthusiast!
Which trains are your favorite trains?
It might make me buy your train.
This is it.
This is your chance.
Train enthusiast.
To tell me your favorite train.
What is this?
Train Simulator...
Oh my god.
What is this?
Isn't this like the...
How is that a train?
We're not spending $15,000 on a train...
Train DLC guys.
Guys, $15,000?
I can buy so many other things.
I can drop by multiple things.
Chat.
We're not spending $15,000.
This is not where our investments go.
Wait!
You know Thomas the Tank Engine?
What kind of train is that?
Is there a train simulator train of Thomas the Tank Engine?
Train Simulator train of Thomas the Tank Engine.
Train Simulator train of Thomas the Tank Engine?
Guys...
Train Enthusiast.
What kind of train is Thomas the Tank Engine?
A tank...
Okay, Mr. Fancy Pants...
A Tank En- He must have an actual train name, okay?
Okay, I get it.
Yes, I know he's a tank engine.
But like what kind of tank engine?
Like yes, I know he's a king.
What's the closest thing?
Oh, an E... Oh my god, you guys actually...
Okay, do I have the E2 locomotive?
E2 loco... locomotive.
Mr. Ashley?
Nooooo!
What do you mean?
How am I supposed to fucking drive Thomas the Tank Engine?
An absolute weakling.
Oh my god.
I need my real train enthusiast.
Do they have the DLC of it though?
Like that's all I wanna know.
Do they have the DLC?
Someone tell me if Thomas the Tank Engine has a similar DLC.
That's all I wanna know.
Type 06OT.
Okay.
06... 06...
O... T...
Okay.
Okay, what the fuck did you like...
made me type?
That was nothing to do with trains.
Nooooo!
All I wanted was to drive a Thomas the Tank Engine.
That's all I want.
That's...
But I couldn't find a simulator that simulated Thomas' train.
I can't believe it.
I was willing to spend money on driving a...
a... a Thomas the Tank Engine.
It might not have been $15,000.
But it was close enough.
It was...
I...
I could have almost spent something...
Something similar to $15,000.
But I couldn't find...
I couldn't find the right train.
Nooooo!
Try the Fowler 4F Loco.
Guys, my train enthusiasts, you're all failing me right now.
You're all...
Guys...
Guys, I thought you knew all of...
I thought you knew.
I thought you knew!
About...
I thought you knew if there were trains that looked like it.
Okay, Fowler.
Ooh, Fowler 4K.
4F Loco.
I mean, I guess it looks like Thomas the...
Thomas the Tank Engine.
Oh, okay.
We'll try that.
All right, I just want to look at it.
Okay.
I'm paying for it.
I bought it.
Alright.
Okay, you're right.
We all fail each other.
Guys, I'm installing the update.
Alright?
Alright, don't worry.
I'm sorry for ever doubting you, my train enthusiast.
I'm sorry for ever doubting you guys.
It's okay.
We found him.
We found Thomas.
Guys.
We found Thomas, guys.
Alright.
It was like $9.
Okay.
Now that I said it out loud, that was a lot.
That was a lot for a train skin, now that I said that.
Okay, maybe it was... maybe...
Maybe it was not the best idea to buy that.
Wait, where's my train?
Where the fuck is my train that I paid money for?
Is that it?
I bought this one, right?
I bought this one.
Holy shit.
What the fuck?
There's so many trains.
There's so many things part of this train.
What the fuck?
Alright.
That's a lot.
There's no face on it, though.
It's okay.
We can... we can pretend.
Oh my god!
What the...
What the fuck?
Guys, I did not learn how to drive this train.
I did not.
Okay.
It's okay.
Things will be okay.
Alright, guys.
We...
Alright, who wants to ride this train?
All the... What the fuck?
This is not fair.
This is actually not... The British Railway is in like... Is this like in...
Where are we?
Is this German?
Is this...
Why are we here?
We're not playing a Thomas song.
I don't want to get copyrighted.
I don't want to share my revenue with fucking a BBC right now.
This is not fair.
How come this train can be so long?
And then my train got like... was too long.
I can't believe it.
Okay.
It feels so wrong to have a British train here in Germany.
Right now.
But like...
Like how did it get here?
How did Thomas... Thomas, how did you get here, Thomas?
Thomas, how did you get here?
There should be no safety for this one.
I refuse to... Oh, wait.
Fuck.
There's... We need water.
God damn it.
Oh, the horn might be cool.
We have the classic horn!
Choo-choo.
Best nine dollars I spent.
Choo -choo.
Choo-choo.
Yay!
It's okay.
If we derail, we derail.
God, this is such a slow train.
Oh no.
How far do we have to go?
This is such a slow train.
Okay.
Stop at Coswick platform four.
Where am I?
Okay.
It's not that bad.
Coswick is here.
And I'm like over here.
It's not that bad.
I thought...
Okay.
But like the train is fucking slow.
Like I... Like this is...
It's... It's... It's getting there.
It's...
It's... It's very lower accurate.
But...
But like, you know, it's getting there.
A better train horn from Choo-choo... Choo-choo Charles.
Am I right?
Zero, thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you.
It's okay.
Wait, can I put more coal?
Blower.
Sounder.
More.
More!
Blow it up!
I want more steam!
Coming out of that hole!
Okay.
There's a reason why I fucking shipped this train to Germany.
I want more steam!
Guys, we're running out of water.
I don't think we're gonna make it.
There's no passages here!
It doesn't matter!
If...
All I'm saying is like, if we run out of water, we'll just abandon the train in the middle of the railway.
It's... It's the government's problem.
It's not my problem after that.
It's not my problem.
I'm a private train owner.
Wait, no.
Railways are monopolized.
Nevermind.
Whoever...
I don't know if the government in Germany owns the railway.
But like, whoever owns this railway, it's their problem.
Not mine.
Oh shit, my brakes were on.
Is that why I was so slow?
That would make sense.
I think?
No, I'm just equally as slow.
It doesn't matter.
It does...
Guys, it doesn't matter!
I'm so fucking slow!
It doesn't matter.
Oh, the water is going down.
Am I closer?
Am I getting closer?
Where am I?
Show task.
Oh, we are...
We are not making it, guys.
We are absolutely not making it, guys.
There is...
There is a long way.
You know what?
We might as well use up all the water.
We might as well.
There is no other choice, guys.
There is no other choice.
If we run out, we leave the train here.
Somebody quick!
Shovel more coal!
Somebody down over there!
And like, I don't know, train number 10!
Train number 10!
Shovel more coal, dragoons!
Shovel more!
We need to get to Coswig platform 4!
Guys, this train is moving even slower.
I can't believe it.
We are at a solid 12.5 miles per hour right now.
It doesn't...
It doesn't matter how...
If I could put that lever to 150...
Like...
It wouldn't matter.
We are at a solid...
Oh my god!
We are going up!
It's 14.7!
Guys...
We made it!
We are at a solid 16.3 now!
This is it.
Choo-choo!
Choo!
Faster!
Oh my god.
Guys, we are over the speed limit.
It says 10, but we are at 20.2, because we don't give a .
We don't care.
Can it get any higher?
Because I don't think so, because we are at 30% water.
But it's okay.
The closer we get there...
The closer we can like...
Just leave the train!
23.5, it's slowly going up guys.
It's slowly going up.
Where are we?
Wait, we might be able to make it!
Guys!
We might be able to make it!
Look!
That's the train!
That's where we need to get!
Guys, I think we can do it.
Guys, I think we can do it guys.
Pressure is dropping?
Where's the pressure?
What do you mean?
What do you mean by pressure?
Is this pressure?
PSI?
Is that what pressure stands for?
Guess it here like a...
Oh hey!
This train is so up in the front right now.
I can't believe this train can have like 20 fucking carts and I can't...
And I can't have like six...
Passenger carts.
Just because I have people in mind.
Like... like who cares?
Like... so what if I have people in my train and they won't let me add more...
Oh wait!
I have a co-pilot?
What the fuck are you?
What the fuck is this old man on my train?
Running low on water?
That's a good time for me to ditch this train then.
It's alright.
If we run out of water, it was just meant to be.
I mean we literally shipped this... a British railway train.
Steam British Railway train to Germany.
We are not keeping this train.
Oh yeah!
The coal shoveler!
That's the dragon who's shoveling coal!
That's you guys!
That's you!
Yeah!
I'm talking about you dragon!
That one dragon over there!
I'm talking about you!
Yes you!
You get the job to be a coal shoveler!
Congratulations!
Guys we don't... we're not making it.
We have 7%.
We have...
We have 7% left.
Guys we're so close too.
That was the... that's the worst part.
We're so close.
This train was never...
No!
That train was never meant to head there.
Alright guys.
Now we're gonna head to Siberia.
Yes.
We're gonna head to Siberia now.
I need to know what this game is.
I need to know.
Guys we're gonna... we're gonna head over.
Yes.
We're gonna head to Siberia.
New game.
It's still trains.
So it still counts.
Guys.
It still has to do with trains guys.
I got curious.
Okay?
Okay I don't know if Sound Guy is still alive.
But we have a new thing to balance for you.
Alright.
Let's see.
Video graphics.
Borderless windows.
Hell yeah.
FPS.
Now why don't we not have unlimited FPS for whatever this game is?
I don't know what this game is.
But what if we don't do that?
Alright.
Sound Guy.
Sound Guy we need you more than ever.
Alright.
Let's see.
I just wanted to punch a bear.
On a train.
Play with survival.
Play without.
Manage the locomotive.
Alright.
We're gonna complete missions for the mafia?
What kind of...
Okay.
Now...
Now I'm curious.
What the fuck is this story mode?
Alright.
What is this?
It's still train related technically.
Hello.
What the fuck?
I have to go to the shop?
I have money?
Oh Billy thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What the fuck is this?
I have flashlights?
Where the fuck...
What is this?
Oh my god there's bread.
There's a knife?
What am I gonna do with a knife?
I thought I'm just driving a train.
Oh I have to go to the mafia shop.
Not the regular shop.
What is this?
It's...
Siberian train station?
Oh it's a simulator.
So I got curious.
Oh my god.
Do I...
Wait.
Where do I have to go?
You're at the...
In the lower... You can see the status of your money.
In the lower right.
On the top level of your characters.
Make sure they're on the right level.
For if any of the stats result in death, pay special attention to the appropriate level of alcohol.
As its absence leads to a constantly worsening health.
Oh my god!
Okay.
I guess...
It's time to buy some...
What the fuck is Spratz?
I'll buy Spratz then.
We don't need lights, we just need alcohol.
Okay, milk, banana.
Uh...
Okay, we'll have...
And then we'll also buy bread.
Oh, we'll buy rye bread.
Alright.
Okay, we have food.
Eating time.
Alright, there we go.
Okay, it's time.
We got this.
I don't know what game I got us into, guys.
I don't know.
It says... It still has train related stuff.
So...
Press I to open more...
Oh my god, that's a lot of inventory.
Go to your locomotive.
Alright, it's time to head to my train.
We'll head to my train now.
My train is so far!
Why is my train so far?
What the... Oh, I have to go up the stairs to get to my train.
Okay.
Guys, we're all here for the train part.
We're just here for the train part, guys.
Alright.
Hypothermia?
What's the temperature?
Oh shit, minus 29 degrees.
Oh, that is cold.
God damn, Siberia is cold.
Holy fuck.
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
I wish I could run faster though.
Because all I wanted to do was drive my train.
That's all.
That's all I wanted to do.
At first, you just enter the locomotive door.
Oh, okay.
Wait, they're speaking Russian.
Oh.
Headlight frame.
Small.
Bro, I don't need any of this.
I'm here to get on my train.
Okay, I opened it.
How do I...
Guys, how do I get on my train, guys?
Guys.
Oh, okay, there we go.
Nice.
Alright.
Oh, and these are like the train...
parts.
And everything.
Oh my god, I can actually look behind me.
Alright.
Battery, current, oh, there we go.
I learned all of this.
Guys, I learned all of this.
The main handle.
We move this.
Wait, stand by the side mirror and press E.
Your inspection mode improves the function of the status...
of the train.
Navigate...
Oh, I have to make sure the train is okay?
What the fuck?
Train simulator didn't teach me this.
How am I supposed to know if my train's okay?
Oh shit, okay, okay.
Guys!
I thought I was ready!
What did train simulator teach me?
I think it looks okay.
Locate the broken part...
and add the adjustable wrench to my inventory.
Oh, there's a broken part here.
What is this?
Is this a mirror?
Oh, it's a speedometer.
Bro, what the fuck?
Okay, I have to fucking grab the speedometer apparently.
I need to fix the speedometer.
Alright.
Okay.
Is that for free?
Do you understand locomotive operation switching procedures and signal meanings?
Yeah.
Joe!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah.
And screw the screws of the speed...
What?
Why did train simulator teach me any of this?
I just know how to press like two buttons.
Sometimes three.
Put away...
If I feel like adventurous, you know?
My god, I'm also an engineer?
Okay.
Put a new speedometer in the empty space.
You can hold the right mouse to move.
I have a new speedometer?
Where the fuck is my speedometer?
I'm also a handyman?
Oh, it's over there.
I'm watching.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Bro, it's 60 dollars?
The mafia is gonna fucking kill me.
And I'm still trying to repair my train.
I thought I was ready.
I thought the fucking train simulator prepared me for this.
I know I had to do all of this shit.
Okay, we don't need banana.
We need.
Okay.
Boom.
And then... tighten the screws up.
Alright.
Here we go.
We're tightening the screws up.
Alright.
You can sell used parts at the courtyard.
Remember to inspect conditions and replace them.
Oh, we can finally start the train!
Alright.
Turn on a small compressor switch in the engine room in the second section of the...
A small what?
What?
I don't wanna get...
I need a crew for this.
What do you mean?
A small... I have to go to another cabin?
Okay.
A small engine room switch.
Guys, this is more of a train simulator than a train simulator.
Because I'm actually doing something on this train.
I'm so pumped.
Just a one-man train conductor.
Where do you find... I'm just so good!
Compress air essentially for safety, banking efficiency, and overall locomotive performance.
The small compressor provides...
Pressure...
Bro, simply repair an entire train.
It's so easy, bro.
Rusty Corn, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
A pantograph is an apparatus mounted on a roof of an electric locomotive to collect power through contacts with...
Oh my god, I'm actually learning what these things are!
That thing up top?
That's called a pantograph.
I'm learning, guys.
Turn on the pantographs, please.
Power switch on the...
Oh my god!
Okay.
Window heating.
I need heat.
Okay.
Field generator.
Compressor.
Engine cooling.
High speed.
Pentagram 1.
Pentagram 2.
Power.
KVC.
Oh my god!
Okay, we got that.
There's more buttons!
Okay, okay.
Electricity.
The red light shows...
The electricity.
Turn on pantograph 1 and 2.
Okay.
Nice.
Main circuit.
Armature circuit.
Okay.
Turn on the heating first set and heating second set.
There's more buttons to the side?!
Okay.
Signalization.
Heating.
Brake.
Second set.
Brake cap.
Okay.
Handles heating.
Lift button.
What the fuck is measuring apparatus illumination?
Oh, okay.
Lights on the dials.
Okay.
Light dial lights.
Brake section.
Second section.
Reservoir.
Venting!
What the fuck do I need a...
What do I need a vent for?
What is this?
What are...
There's a manual?
You will Buy...
Oh my god...
There's so much.
There's so much!
Oh my god...
Welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
What is that just saw going?
Bear!
What do you mean?
This is more of a fucking train simulator!
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, keep the doors and windows closed.
Okay.
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
Closed.
Oh, I need to close the door!
I need to close the door!
No, I'm letting the heat out!
Close the door!
Ugh.
Okay.
I gotta make sure I keep the heat in!
Oh my god.
This is what train simulator taught me.
Nice.
Alright, turn on the radio.
Is this the radio?
At least I have the radio.
Alright.
Can we go on the train now?
This was information for your care...
You press the call button to listen.
Okay.
Hello?
Alright.
Now what?
Okay, next step is to turn... My engine's not on yet?!
Where you at?
My engine's not on!
Oh, the compressor.
Okay.
Compressor.
Compressor switch.
Alright.
Nice.
We're turning it on!
Okay.
And then... that starts the controller for the...
Oh my god.
The KVC needs to be reset?
How do I...
Oh, here.
Alright.
Okay, it means it's working.
That's good.
Turn on the BV1.
Oh god.
Okay, I turn it on.
Okay.
Alright.
And then... BVS.
What did I do?
I don't know.
What the fuck is this?
And the red light in the second row means that the engines are turned off.
We lower them and then raise them up.
Remember we set the...
I am not gonna remember any of this!
Oh my god!
The turn on the...
Guys, I found another game for train simulator enthusiasts, guys.
And I just wanted to shoot a gun.
It's located above the entrance in the cabin?
What?
Oh, it's up here.
Where is it?
What is this?
Turn on the VO2.
Activate the locomotive control system?
Holy shit.
What?
Is this all the buttons?
Guys, I am not gonna remember this, guys.
Guys!
Well, turning on the VU.
This is the VU, right?
Okay, we always need to turn this on.
Turn on the specialization system.
Go to the engine room in the...
Oh, okay.
The engine room is here.
Okay.
Yeah.
How do I turn it to the forward?
How do I...
How do I do that?
My arms!
Oh!
Oh, there it is.
No, that's not what I do.
Okay.
Guys.
Guys, I can't turn it.
Oh, there.
Wait.
How do I do that?
Guys.
Guys, my biggest issue.
I can't turn this.
I can't.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, okay.
Nope, I went the wrong way.
That's not it.
Okay.
Go forward.
Forward!
Oh, there.
I did it.
There, I did it.
Nice.
On the left in the first section.
Okay.
And then turn on the attention control.
Are we going yet?
Sun.
Okay.
Close attention.
But to...
But...
Oh!
Oh, that's the attention!
That's it is!
That's the attention button!
Green light means that the movement is allowed up to 60.
I need alcohol.
I need a fucking...
I need vodka.
This Russian needs vodka right now.
All right.
You know what it means?
I gotta slow down before...
I'm not gonna remember all of this.
We're just gonna head to the next destination.
Okay.
That's like my main goal.
The moment I get to a destination, I'm happy.
Like I'm literally like starving and like almost hungover right now.
And like I need water and everything.
And I'm still trying to figure this out.
White light means that the nearest rail signal has not been detected and you have to proceed.
Next step is to prepare the brake which is used.
You need to fill the air brake system of the locomotive.
The system utilizes...
So slowing down.
To brake a locomotive.
I'm gonna...
A different brake.
It will be discussed...
It will be discussed later?
What do you mean it will be discussed later?
Guys, this is not looking too good for Doki.
Yes.
This is not looking too good.
Set the handle...
Main brake handle to release.
Okay.
I don't know if I can do all of that.
But okay.
I don't know what any of these mean.
You can brake longer and harder.
Okay.
Position release and charge.
Set the main brake handle to the service position.
There we go.
Alright.
Okay.
There we go.
Reach the value.
Oh my god.
Oh my.
This should be like after you master train some of your...
You know, the train simulator.
You get to do this.
That should be like...
This is like the true test of your train knowledge.
Like you learn everything from the train simulator and then you go straight into Siberia.
I'm just...
I bet all the train enthusiasts knows what I'm doing right now.
I think they know what I'm doing.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna f**king...
I'm gonna drink my milk.
I'm too...
I'm sad.
I need to drink my milk.
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh.
Service.
There we go.
We're still...
They talking about the brake situation?
Oh.
Press F to continue.
Okay.
If you would like to send more pre...
I don't care about if...
If our f**king train can't brake, it's fine.
Just make the train go.
Insert the second...
Go to the cabin in the second...
Oh my god.
Let me through.
I need to go to the second cabin.
Why do I need to go to the second cabin?
Oh my god.
Let me through.
Okay.
Is this the second cabin?
Oh no.
Here we go.
This has to be the second cabin.
Right?
Is this it?
Wait.
This is connected.
Wait a minute.
This was connected the entire time.
I didn't have to go outside.
Oh my god.
There's a...
There's me.
I'm so sad.
Okay.
There's more like this.
All right.
There's the back side.
Okay.
It's at the handle.
Breaking out to handle breaking release position and deactivate it.
Is it not here?
Oh, there's a...
What is this?
I don't know what it is.
Okay.
Return to the...
I can close this then.
All right.
Well, we figured out there's a second side to the cabin.
That this train was connected all the line.
I did not have to...
Oh, set the handle to blocking.
Oh my god, I have to go back.
Do I have to go back?
Where was it?
Set the...
Wait, blocking handle to handbrake.
Oh, I did!
Can I do that?
Or do I have to do it on the other side?
Oh, it's on the other side!
There's two sides.
I'm getting disoriented.
There's too many sides.
There's too many sides!
Okay, here.
Oh my god, there's too many.
I thought this was gonna be a shooting game.
Instead, I get more accurate train simulator.
Set the handler to M.
M.
Okay.
Is this the right M?
Oh, this is M.
M.
Set this to 1.
Okay.
There we go.
If you apply too much power, the white light on the right panel will appear and the wheel will not be able to...
You have to reduce the power.
Next step is to connect to the marked railway wagon.
Drive forward until you pass the correct railway switch.
Don't drive too fast.
You have to brake soon.
Okay, am I driving?
What if I just go a little faster?
There you go.
Oh my god, I'm going!
I'm going forward!
Guys, I'm doing it!
We're doing it, guys!
Oh my god, we finally figured it out.
Oh my god, wait!
I can play a cassette player?
Oh my god, there's so many things.
Okay, we gotta put this...
to...
zero so we can...
Wait, it's so far.
We're in.
Okay.
Here I crank it.
No, we can't!
It won't let me!
It actually stops me!
Alright.
Where's the train button?
The whistle button?
There has to be a whistle button here, right?
Alright, don't worry.
Oh, we have to slow down now.
We have to slow down.
No!
Oh, god.
Oh, shit.
The door is open.
Whoops.
Guys, I fucked up, guys.
Guys.
We drove past it, guys.
Guys, I don't...
Guys.
Brake?
Guys, we drove past it, guys.
Okay.
I have an idea.
Brake applied.
Locomotive.
Where's the locomotive?
Where is it?
I forgot which one it is.
Guys, we're so far.
There it is!
Alright.
We did it!
Wait for the train to stop.
And then, we go on reverse.
This is what it taught me!
Alright.
And then, wait for the train to stop.
Okay, the speedometer is going...
I was set up for failure!
Go outside and change the railway road.
Are you fucking kidding me?
It's so far!
I drove...
Noooooooooooo!
It's even further!
No!
It's taking me a while!
I drove too far!
I'm mad!
Oh, I can't punch you.
Never mind.
Wait, I can just reverse the train?
Oh my god, you guys are so smart.
Let me run back to the train.
Let me run back to my train.
I don't know!
The tutorial was like go outside and I'm a sheep.
So I was like, okay.
I'll go outside and run back to the train.
Wait, can I drive from here?
Oh my god.
Wait!
Everything changed!
Wait, it won't let me guys.
Guys!
Guys, I can't move any of the buttons because it wants me to run.
because it wants me to run.
Guys, it's making me run.
No!
Wait, I don't have to?
Okay, wait.
Maybe I'm just stupid.
I just don't know enough about trains.
Oh, I have to do the brakes on the other side.
Okay, I got this.
Guys, my train, everything is like running out right now on my train.
But it's okay.
Alright, we gotta figure this out.
Guys.
Okay.
I don't...
What's this?
What was that?
Attention.
Guys, it's not letting me...
Guys, it's actually not letting me play the game.
Guys, it's not letting me play the game.
Guys, I can't move anything.
They want me to run back.
No!
I can't move anything.
It actually wants me to run back.
No!
Yay!
Whee!
No!
Guys, I can't.
Guys, it doesn't matter.
I can't press anything.
It won't let me.
It won't let me press anything, guys.
I can't even fucking move the brake.
It won't let me.
Guys, I think it does want me to walk back.
Actual punishment.
Guys, why didn't you stop me?
It's time for the walk of shame.
I can't believe it.
I should have bought a gun.
I should have bought a gun from the mafia's shop.
I got to enjoy about 30 seconds of actually driving the train.
And then they put me back onto the road.
They're making me do the run of shame.
The run of shame!
I got the fuel what it's like to drive a train for 30 seconds.
And then I fucked up.
And now it's punishing me.
It's actually punishing me.
I can't believe it.
It won't let me drive the train backwards.
Train simulator let me drive the train backwards.
But now... Oh my god it's so fine.
It's actually so fine.
The price of failure.
Alright here you go.
Now back to the train I go.
Okay.
Here we go.
I overshot.
Yeah I sort of... I went too fast.
I was like hee hee I'm gonna put it to 6.
I'm gonna put the handle on.
I'm gonna put the handle to 6 and go fast.
Then...
Sometimes... Sometimes life is not about going fast chat.
Not in Siberia that's for sure.
Why is she outside?
I'm in Siberia.
I'm in the real train simulator now.
I thought I... I thought...
I learned a lot from train simulator.
I thought I was actually doing so well.
And like you know actually processing how to...
How to drive a train.
But I didn't realize there was more to trains than just 3 buttons.
There's so many more buttons.
There's so many buttons guys.
Alright.
We put... put that there.
And then...
Here we go.
Okay.
Reverse!
Alright.
Get that brake out of here.
There we go.
Release.
Oh okay okay.
It's 8.
Alright.
We finally hit it a little bit right?
Connect this slowly.
Do not exceed the...
You can observe the train in inspection mode.
What happens if we hit it?
Does it punish us for it?
We're gonna find out.
No.
That'll be fine right?
I mean it's 500 meters away.
Ooh it's getting faster.
Ooh now it's 400 guys.
Woah it's going so fast.
Woah!
Okay this is going way too fast.
Oh no!
Okay.
Okay!
Oh!
There we go!
We should be fine!
Okay, it's still going a little bit fast.
Okay, there we go.
Alright.
I wanna see the... See, now it's okay!
Now it's like an okay distance.
We should be able to connect this.
The game won't punish me, right?
No.
It would never!
Why would the game punish me?
See?
Look how slow we're going!
Look at that!
Oh my god!
What the f***?
That's how it ends?
No!
Alright, if you guys want more, you can buy the game.
I think... I think I'm done with my train career, guys.
I think... I think I'm done.
I think I'm gonna retire.
I don't wanna load it.
I think I'm gonna retire here.
We had a good run.
We had a... My train career is over.
You can't...
You can't recover from that.
I'm scared.
I'm scared people are gonna...
I'm scared people are gonna send me to the gulags.
I don't understand!
How is like...
Driving a plane...
Easier than driving a train.
Like... It's just backwards and forwards!
Why is there more buttons?
Why?
Why was there more buttons than a plane?
Oh my god!
You know what?
Best like... 15...
How much did I spend for that like 30 minutes of gameplay?
I played like 30 minutes of this...
Of the train Siberia.
How much did I pay for?
Okay, 20 Canadian dollars.
That's fine.
That was... That was a good 20 dollars to spend it on.
Um...
RustyCorn!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Two hours well spent.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
WB!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Train Simulator Classic is more of a default experience.
Train Sim World is more of the expand experience.
Similar to this.
Wait!
What's Train Sim World?
Train Sim World.
Train Sim World?
Can I like...
What's Train Sim World?
How much is Train Sim World?
Oh my god!
That's 51 dollars.
Wait!
What's the difference between Train Sim World and like... Train...
Uh...
Then like... Train Simulator?
Train Simulator!
Wait!
What's the difference?
Wait.
I need to see what the difference is.
There is more?!
There is more to the....
There is more Train Sims?
How much more?
Okay, Train Sim World, was it worth it...
Oh my god!
Wait!
Okay, guys.
Not over.
Stream's not over.
Guys.
Guys, guys, we're... Dream's not over, don't leave!
Dream's not over!
Okay, $51, that's alright.
Okay, let me continue payment.
Alright, don't worry, it's a business expense.
It's a business expense, guys.
Alright, how many gigabytes is this?
Okay, 29 gigabytes.
Okay, we're fine.
That's fine.
That's okay.
29 giga... the other one was also like 25...
25 gigabytes, so we're fine there.
The ride never ends!
It's time for another train!
Guys, don't leave!
We have more trains, guys!
There's more trains!
You thought it was over?
Alright, let me watch this review video.
If it was worth it.
I want...
This Doki is a wild ride.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki Train Funds.
Oh my god!
There's a...
Wait!
I should play this train simulator!
I can go back to...
in my simulator!
Yeah, I'm watching the review after the fact that I purchased.
I don't know what's going on.
Guys, I can go...
I can go visit the cabin!
Afterwards, mysteriously!
Thank you for the five gifted chips!
Guys, the ride's not over!
Get back into the train!
Guys, get back into the train!
Guys, the ride's not over!
We went to Siberia, and now we're getting back on the train!
I'm 10 gigabytes.
Don't worry, we have 10 more gigabytes left.
Get in the train, Dragoons!
Get in the fucking train!
Dragoons, I spent...
Today, I spent like...
at least $80 today on just trains.
Guys, we are gonna make sure this was worth it!
We are gonna stretch that out!
I spent $80 for this one stream for as long as I can!
Until I think it was worth the money!
We need to pay off our train debt!
AirPodNinja, thank you!
Thank you!
I went off of MissDoki's wild ride!
Guys, I'm on a...
I have a debt right now to the train mafia, so we gotta make sure we make enough money today.
And then...
to justify all these purchases, guys.
Please let...
No!
Nobody is getting off the train until the ride's over.
Until we played all the train sims games today.
Nobody is leaving this ride until all the train simulator games are over.
Chat.
Someone please pay her.
I'm waiting.
I am waiting, guys.
I'm just waiting, guys.
We are almost there, chat.
We're almost there.
It is...
27 more gigabytes left!
Woo!
Zechra, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The Doki Express is now available for purchase.
It's been stopping for a while, squad.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What is that?
That train movie?
Train movie where the world is in the train and if the train stops, you die?
Snowpiercer!
Yes!
We're just like Snowpiercer!
Guys, and that's a good thing.
I'm keeping you all alive.
Guys.
Guys, I'm keeping you all alive in my Snowpiercer train.
Squad, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm not leaving.
I'm just getting out to hit the track switch.
I swear.
No!
Nobody is getting out to hit the track switch.
Only I can hit the track switch, guys, because I know what I'm doing.
I went through a 30-minute tutorial in Russia on how to hit the track switch before I died.
Squad, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This is the train derail.
Look, I said I'm the better version of the Snowpiercer and it's not going to derail.
It finished.
It finished installing.
We gotta thank that one guy who suggested the train sim world chat.
We have to thank him for introducing me to more train games chat.
I can't believe none of you guys suggested this.
What are you trying to hide?
Why are you trying to hide more train games?
Okay.
There we go.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
What is this, like, thirst trap video of the train?
What is this?
Whoa!
Oh, my God.
What a thirst trap.
These trains are so high-end.
They're like HD.
That's some HD train.
Oh, my God.
Look at the...
Oh, look at all these buttons I can press.
I wonder if I can call the phone.
That's a slick-ass train.
There is audio, but it's, like, super quiet.
Railroads are a dangerous place and you should never attempt to replicate or copy activities you see in-game on the real railroad.
I don't think, like...
Us regular people are allowed to, like, drop... steal a train.
I don't think we're gonna be allowed to be on that train anyway.
I have to...
Oh, no.
I don't wanna register it.
No thanks.
Uh...
No, thank you.
Character select.
I wanna be old.
Uh...
I have read...
Oh, okay.
See real world advertisements?
Sure.
Alright.
Um...
Recommended bait...
Get started with training.
Uh...
Standard experience...
Jump to the main...
You know what?
We don't need the instructions!
We already have the...
Uh...
The original train simulator.
Okay.
Let's see.
Uh...
To the trains we go.
Pick a train.
To the train.
I'll send it to the train bus as soon as possible.
Something else.
Ta-da!
Anyway.
What the hell did I do?
Uhh!
Uh...
for the won...
Especially, for the game.
In Strat here...
somebody need to complete this together.
Wait, I wanna... I wanna like... Oh my god, where the fuck is the sensitivity?
Adjust settings, there we go.
Okay, let's see.
Left mouse.
Okay, we definitely need to adjust the sensitivity.
I think everything else is fine.
Alright, I don't know the sound... oh yeah, sound guy.
Uh... alright.
Alright, here.
Oh my god, why is this... why is this... this sensitivity so bad?
Okay, controllers.
Alright, we do have two.
This should be better.
I don't need instructions!
Lock or door... nobody can leave.
Wow!
Nobody can leave.
Oh, I can make the desk light lighter.
Active!
Oh, attention!
That's the attention button!
They removed the brake.
Why did they remove the brake?
This controls the direct...
Set the headlights to indicate that this train is operational.
Yeah!
The train is operational, guys!
Oh, let's open the window!
I want the fresh air!
How do I turn this on?
Oh, hey, what's this?
What is that?
Oh, I turned it off.
Okay.
What's this?
There's so many buttons!
We don't need... wait.
Parking... wait.
Parking brake release.
Did I not turn on the lights?
Oh, there it is!
On!
Oh, I took the brakes with me!
Release brake handle.
Why did I take the brake with me?
Release.
Okay, there's motion blur going in here.
I need to get that shit away.
Like, why is there motion blur when I'm driving my train?
What the fuck?
HUD advanced settings.
Okay, there we go.
Post view... wait.
There's no motion blur?
I can feel the motion blur, but I can't turn it...
Max FPS is 62?
No, I need good frames for my driving.
I...
I can't believe it.
I can't believe I can't turn on motion...
I can feel the motion blur, too.
I know it's there!
You can't lie to me!
I have gamer eyes!
I know it's there!
You can't lie to me!
I have gamer eyes!
I know it's there!
You can't lie to me!
I have gamer eyes!
I can feel the motion blur!
Oh, is that the train brake to drive?
Okay.
Oh.
Unlock all doors.
Guys, you can come on the train now!
Wait, I wanna see!
I wanna see!
I wanna see you guys get in!
Screw this tutorial!
It won't let me see!
I don't understand!
I said skip tutorial and it won't let me see.
See you!
Left doors closed.
Okay, I need to close all doors.
All doors are locked now.
Nobody can leave.
Nice.
Alright.
Let's go.
Hey guys, the window is open.
Let the air in!
Let it all in!
Oh,
okay.
Speeding.
Apply a small amount of braking force by moving the master controller into the room.
You're making me stop at a location?
What if I don't want to stop?
Oh wait, no.
That's where you guys have to get off.
Never mind.
You guys have to stop there.
I want to get off.
I want to stand up.
You're now approaching the station.
Begin applying a small amount of braking force by moving the master controller into the room.
Oops.
Whoops.
Almost an emergency brake.
Oh, that was awkward.
It said small and I'm sort of...
It said nice job!
Alright.
Get off the train, guys.
Get off!
Alright.
Close doors and drive to the next station unguided.
Oh, I cannot!
I don't need to be guided anymore!
Guys!
They're not gonna guide me!
I'm not closing my window.
You can't stop me.
My windows are gonna be open.
I want to get off this...
Okay.
Am I driving?
Why am I not driving?
What did I do?
How did I fuck it up already?
Oh, it's because I need to do it 100, right?
Start.
Start!
How did I mess it up?
Drive.
Guys, how did I mess this up already?
It's already locked!
Everything is locked.
I made sure.
I made sure everything was locked.
Okay.
Drive.
Guys, she left me and now I don't know how I fucked it up.
Guys!
Guys, she left me and I've somehow fucked it up.
I don't know what I did.
How did I mess it up?
Oh, I did it!
Yeah!
I did it!
I don't know what I did.
Yeah!
Okay.
And then...
I'm level 2 driver!
I got an achievement!
Chat!
Oh my god!
Okay, wait.
Instrumental light.
Lights off.
You guys...
Wait, cab, train lights?
Wait, you guys don't need lights.
Okay, instrument lights.
Sander off.
Where do I have to go?
Where's my next stop?
Is it that one?
In 500 meters?
You guys don't need lights.
I can't even see you guys!
It won't let me leave the train!
It's not fair!
I can literally see the door!
I can see the door!
I know you guys are there!
Alright, emergency breaks again.
It's okay.
It works, guys.
Yay!
Alright.
And then...
Alright, now you guys can leave.
If you want to.
Why is there glue on the seats?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I did it!
Yay!
I'm so good!
Okay, what's next round?
I want to go to... I don't want to train anymore.
I want to actually drive.
Alright.
To the train.
Jump straight in.
Do something more.
I want to be able to walk around.
You did it, Shroud.
I knew you were a train conductor at heart, Shroud.
I fucking knew it.
Oh my god, I don't... what the fuck was it?
What are we... what?
What is this train?
What the fuck?
Guys, I cannot see.
Guys, I can't see the train.
Guys, how do I turn on the light?
This train is too high tech.
I don't like this train.
It's too high tech for me.
Guys, I don't like this train.
This train has too many buttons.
What do you mean?
Help.
Wait, why is this train digital?
I'm leaving.
I can't do this train, guys.
This train is too much for this tomato.
This train...
Alright.
To the trains.
Okay.
Pick a train.
Rail journeys.
Got it.
I don't want like... I don't want people to help me.
Why is quick play like...
Why is quick play like... not... not something I can do myself?
I want to be able to get up and move.
I don't want some lady to tell me how to drive a train.
There's at least six buttons.
Is this the same thing?
Or can I...
Oh no.
Oh yeah, this is the same thing.
Okay.
So apparently in quick play, it's just like...
Quick play is just to fool you.
To do tutorial.
Okay.
Alright.
To the train.
Train depot.
I guess...
We'll do...
Jump into a lifelike.
Okay, lifelike.
Alright, what do we want?
Guys, what train do we want?
Guys.
What is a cool train?
Which one was the one that had so many like buttons?
I don't like that train.
Choose a route?
What train do we get, guys?
Which train is cool?
801?
Alright.
801.
That train.
London's King Cross.
We'll do that.
I want to be able to get up.
I want to be able to explore the train cabins.
Which one runs on coal?
Alright, how do I leave?
Why is there more butt?
What the f...
How do I get up?
Setting control.
Okay.
Reset automatic.
I want to get up.
That's all I want.
Press E?
Oh, E.
Okay.
Yes!
Oh my god.
Guys.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Alright.
We got to open the door first.
Where's the door?
Down later.
Okay, you're not getting lights.
Oh!
There we go.
I'm making sure you guys get...
Okay.
Here we go.
We're going to put it on auto.
Put that on off.
And then we're going to put...
Where the f...
Is DSD?
Reading light.
Don't worry, guys.
I got you guys.
I got the reading light on too.
Guys, I got you guys.
Where are the doors?
I got everything.
But...
Oh, door release.
Are you guys...
CCTV?
The door release?
I'm loading passengers.
Am I loading passengers?
Are you guys getting in?
Oh!
Sorry.
Are you guys scared?
Holy f...
I got scared the shit out of me.
Oh!
Who are you?
Wrong game.
What is this fucking platform 8 shit?
I haven't played platform 8 yet.
Where's the microwave?
There's people here!
Hello, dragons!
I'm your conductor today.
Guys!
Hey!
I'm your conductor today.
How are you guys doing?
I'm...
I'm just doing!
You guys had a great time trying to find the microwave.
I know there's like supposed to be a microwave here.
I'm trying to find it right now.
You guys know where the microwaves are?
I saw it on the trailer.
On the trailer there was a microwave.
I just want to know where it is.
We can't get off the train?
Oh my god!
I'm fucking free!
Is there a microwave here?
I don't know.
What about here?
Oh my god!
It's the back of the train!
There's the back of the train!
This train doesn't have...
There it is!
This is what I saw guys!
The microwave!
Wait, I can't even use the microwave!
9 out of 10.
Can't use the microwave.
I'm so sad.
Oh, this is like the VIP, the first class lounge.
There's nobody rich enough to be in the first class seat?
Dragons!
What's going on?
I'm so sad.
I'm going to get in the first class.
Guys!
Come on!
Get in my train!
Guys!
Come on!
I know you guys have the money to pay for first class!
You literally live in London!
You think I don't know that?
Only the rich british live in London!
Get on the first class!
Pay for my first class ticket!
You live in London!
I know you have money there!
Let me tell you!
I'm fucking lie...
I don't know.
London Red is very expensive!
Oh wait, maybe you guys...
But you guys would just drive in the car.
You would not be on the train.
My bad.
I forgot like...
I forgot that...
You would have your own car.
You would not be on a train.
Can't afford first class.
Spend it all on turkey bridge.
Thank you for the super chat cast.
Thank you.
Okay.
Close.
We are closing the doors now.
Door closed.
Okay.
On!
Uh...
Oh, I want to start wiping the windshields.
Okay.
I have to make sure our windshield is being wiped right now.
Windshield wiper speed 10.
And then engine start.
Uh...
Guess there is a lot of buttons.
Is it wiping my windshield?
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Okay.
We got that.
Uh...
Oh hey, it's starting to wipe.
Are we... Guys!
Give me a sec!
It's my first time on this train!
Forward.
Where's the other?
Where's the other one?
Where's the other lever?
Oh, there you go!
Am I going forward?
Am I not going forward?
Why am I...
My windshield is going up.
Guys, we might be a little late.
This is my first time driving this train.
Brake?
There is a brake?
There's so...
Where's the brake?
What?
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Hello?
I don't know where the brake is.
Can somebody call me back?
Guys, I don't know where the brake is.
Somebody call me back, please.
Please!
Don't get so scared and confused.
Oh...
Forward.
Where is it?
Where's the...
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Oh no, we don't need to open that door.
Is that it?
Local door.
Door of release.
Guys!
This ain't funny anymore.
Where's...
Where's forward?
Master key is on!
I'm going forward!
Uh...
Where is it?
Oh, brake.
Is that from Snowpiercer?
Oh, there it is!
Okay.
Brake release.
Is that it?
Guys, who's driven this train before?
Has anyone else drove this train before?
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Guys!
Has anyone else drove this train before?
We need to figure this out.
Ha ha ha ha!
Guys, this is very important.
We need... Oh, there's a cup holder.
We need to know how to go forward.
Guys!
Just go outside and push it.
What's the drive button?
There's a horn button!
There's no drive!
I'm fucking windshield!
And then start.
Start!
Lisa?
Yes.
Yeah.
Check the... There's no manual!
I chose this train!
You guys picked this train!
I thought you knew what you're doing when you all picked this train!
I thought you guys knew what you're doing!
Ha ha ha ha!
You all picked this train together!
It's already maxed!
Ha ha ha ha!
Oh my god!
I let you guys pick this train!
Ha ha ha ha!
Start engine!
Start!
Okay.
I started.
Alright, I started the engine.
Guys, it doesn't look like the engine started, guys.
It does not.
Guys, we're very behind schedule.
Okay.
Someone announced...
That we're...
That we're about to start?
Like pretend that...
Okay.
Guys, pretend that we know what we're doing.
Uhhhhhh...
Ha ha ha!
Guys, the...
The red light?
Start.
Start!
Hey...
Uhhhhhh...
Turn the reading light on.
Ha ha ha ha!
The yellow button that says... Oh!
Electric!
I don't know.
I hope there's no backlog of cars behind us, guys.
of cars behind us, guys.
That would be pretty awkward.
If there's like a backlog of cars behind us.
Ha ha ha ha!
There's like a lot of people just waiting on us right now.
We're figuring this out.
Close the door?
The doors are all closed!
I made sure of it!
What am I...
Oh, my door.
It's fine.
You don't need to know.
I can close it now.
Local door.
Close door.
Door closed.
Interlocked.
Okay.
Control panel.
Oh, maybe it's the fuse.
No, everything is fine there.
Oh, maybe it's back here!
Okay.
Isolated.
Guys, we're behind schedule!
Doki's...
The conductor is learning how to ride this car.
The other cab?
There's no way it has anything to do with the other cab.
Guys, sorry.
I'm sorry.
I'm just learning.
Ha ha ha ha!
Guys, look.
I know you're waiting for the other train.
Guys!
I'm sorry.
I'm just learning!
I'm learning!
Okay.
Alright.
How do I close this door?
There we go.
Alright.
Guys, I'm sorry.
Your trains will be delayed a little bit too, guys.
Your train will also be delayed a little bit.
Ha ha ha!
We're gonna figure this out!
Do not worry!
Guys, I'm worrying a little bit.
Guys...
Guys, I'm...
I'm a little worried, guys.
Just a little worried.
There's another door?
Where's the other door?
Oh.
How do I close this door?
Door...closed.
Uh...
Door...oh!
Door closed.
Nobody's getting out.
Nobody's getting out of here.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright.
Okay.
Now!
Now we got this.
Engine start.
And then...
Oh.
Reverse or forward?
And BOOM!
Guys!
BOOM!
Oh, the panograph is down?
Panograph up.
Electric.
BOOM!
Guys, I don't...
Guys...
Ha ha ha!
I don't think we're moving, guys.
I don't think we're moving.
Ha ha ha!
Why can't we...
Can't we move our...
Train?
All I wanna do is drive this train!
Ha ha ha!
No!
We're not...
We're not an Arab!
I need a... We just don't know how to start the car!
That's really it!
We don't know how to start the car!
We're all stupid!
We're...
Ha ha ha!
It's an us issue!
We don't know what to do!
Ha ha ha!
We?
Yes, we!
None of us!
Do you know what to do?
Ha ha ha!
What are you... Alright!
No, no!
This is a team effort!
You can't do this to me!
You're here!
Jack Goose, you're on my train!
This is literally a team effort!
Ha ha ha!
Why are you on my train if it's not a team effort?
This... What does it say about you guys?
Jack Goose!
You're on this train with us!
Come into the passenger!
Come into the conductor chamber!
We're all gonna try to figure this out till you're there!
Ha ha!
Passengers!
This is a group effort!
I have train enthusiasts in my chat!
Ha ha ha!
Go out!
Go outside and push the train!
Ha ha ha!
We're conducting together!
We are conducting this together!
Ha ha ha!
You're not!
You're gonna get fired from your job if we don't figure this out!
You're gonna be late for your job because you're on this train!
If you don't figure... If we don't figure this out together, we just don't know what to do!
Exactly!
You wanna go to work?
You gotta help me figure out how to start the train!
Ha ha ha!
The simulation world is anger!
It's time to learn to be a train enthusiast!
Guys!
We don't simulate stress!
We're all gonna be stressed now!
Alright!
Maybe we acknowledge!
And then we press this!
And then we... we slip-slide!
I don't know what the fuck this... I don't know!
What does this mean?
Push?
I got experience points for that!
What did I press?
Oh!
It started beeping at me!
Guys!
I'm scared!
The game started beeping at me!
Ha ha ha!
Guys!
The game started beeping at me!
I don't know if that's a good or bad thing!
Ha ha ha!
Where are my dragoon conductors?
Where did they go?
Okay.
Alright.
And then we press forward.
Why is it beeping?
Why are you beeping?
What did I do wrong?
Ha ha ha!
Why you beep?
I don't understand!
Why you beeping?
Okay.
Forward.
Boom!
Oh no!
Press!
Please!
Somebody help!
Ha ha ha!
There's a break release?
Oh my god!
How is there a break release?
Ha ha ha!
Please!
Somebody help!
Okay.
Press signal.
PSD panel.
Hazard warning.
Please I am the hazard.
We're gonna open this door.
Ha ha ha!
Great button!
Press.
Okay.
Go!
Please!
Please go!
Ha ha ha!
Please!
Why don't you move?
My track clothes need to go to work!
Ha ha ha!
Please!
My track clothes need to go to work!
Ha ha ha!
Okay.
Control cut.
There has to be a...
cause...
we've been stuck here for a very long time.
Ha ha ha!
Where are the instruction manuals?
Where do I have... where's my instruction manuals?
Ha ha ha!
Okay.
We're at 10.
We pressed it but it won't let me Guys this train is too complex.
I'm getting a tutorial.
Ha ha ha!
Hey what?
Fuck this.
I'm learning how to drive.
I'm gonna learn how to drive this stupid train!
Explore on foot?
Alright.
Which train is this again?
Is this a Metro Link?
Which one did we play?
Who is this one?
We gotta learn how to drive this stupid train.
Ha ha ha!
Was it this train?
Was this the train?
Ha ha ha!
Was this it?
This was the train.
I should have learned.
I should have learned how to drive this train in the beginning.
Ha ha ha!
The conductor left the train to go back to school.
I should have learned how to drive a BF-8301 electric motor.
Yeah!
Thank you sir!
How do I drive this train?
You will be taken through the critical driving controls.
And...
I left the train.
The conductor rage quit the last train.
And now she's back at train school.
I did it.
Wait I literally just boarded the train.
Oh I mean I could do that again.
Ha ha ha!
Don't worry I'm gonna...
I did it.
Alright.
For this introduction, you will be completing a full loop of the circuit.
And performing passenger operations when you reach the next stop.
Prepare the train for departure.
Alright.
Master key.
The reverser is used to determine the direction of travel.
Wait what?
What?
Oh it wants me in neutral.
Set the headlights.
As this will let others around you...
Is it this?
Did I not set the headlights?
Is this why?
Ha ha ha!
Was it the headlights this entire time?
What does it want me to set to?
Switch to dim.
Okay.
Was it the headlights this entire time?
You need to open the passenger doors.
There's no way.
There's no way they forcefully stop me.
Okay.
Door has been released guys.
And trap everybody inside.
Ha ha ha ha Ha ha ha ha ha Ha ha ha ha ha Alright.
Come in everybody.
Guys.
Come into the train.
Again.
Wait.
There's nobody here.
Are there people inside my train?
Wait.
There's nobody on my train.
Guys!
I'm not like the last...
Guys, I'm changed!
Guys!
Guys, I know I fucked up last time on the train, but I'm different now!
Guys, it's different!
Guys!
I swear!
Guys, I know I fucked up last time on the train, but I'm different now!
Guys, I know you might have heard about my reputation on that last train, Guys, I know you might have heard about my reputation on that last train, where I left a...
where we didn't start the train and I left a bunch of dragoons stranded.
But I'm different now!
Dragoons!
I'm different now!
Alright, close!
Right, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you!
Ok,
forward.
Ok...
And then what?
How come this went...
What?
It was the lights.
It was the fucking headlights!
Oh my god!
I'm fucking going back.
I'm...
I'm going back to the main...
We figured it out.
We fucking figured it out, guys.
Guys, we figured it out.
It was the headlights.
It was the headlights all this time.
Going back to the...
It was the headlights.
Okay.
We figured it out.
Alright, guys!
Round two!
Get in, guys.
Get in.
Guys, I figured it out.
Yeah!
Come into the train, everybody!
Come into the train!
Doki, the conductor knows how to drive trains for real now.
This time for real.
The conductor actually knows what she's doing this time.
Guys...
I fucking knew it.
I knew it.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Uh...
Dimmed.
Okay.
There we go.
I fucking knew it.
This was the issue all along.
It was the lights.
Okay.
Close the door.
Alright.
We figured it out.
Forward.
Bam!
Everybody!
Oh my god!
This calls for a celebration!
Wind wiper!
Wooo!
Guys!
We figured it out!
Dracons!
Are you guys ex-
Oh, this is bad.
Oh, this is so bad.
This is so bad.
Oh, stop.
The train stopped.
I want to wear it.
Oh!
Oh, shit!
Don't worry, guys.
The train stopped!
It'll be fine!
Oh, my god!
I was close.
Don't worry.
Everything's gonna be fine!
It's okay, the train...
The train stopped, guys.
Thank god.
Don't worry, guys.
Conductor is coming back.
Everything is okay.
It's okay.
Oh, shit.
Everything is okay guys!
I'm okay!
I'm alive!
Guys!
Did you guys see that?
I was so... Everything will be okay guys!
Everything... Alright, okay.
Okay, let's get some air in here too.
Get some air into the system.
Alright, um...
Was that an emergency brake?
Oh, brake release.
Uh, neutral.
Uh, min brake.
Okay.
The light is on.
Forward!
Go!
Are we going now?
Guys, why aren't we going anymore?
Guys, what did I do wrong?
Oh, it's the doors!
It's the doors!
Okay.
Alright.
Press the pedal.
Guys, why aren't we going?
No!
Guys, I celebrated too early and now we're not going anymore.
Guys,
I celebrated too early.
Guys, I fucked up.
Alright.
Okay.
Uh...
Forward.
Go!
I don't understand.
I don't...
Guys, I got too excited.
I'm sorry.
I got too excited.
I got too happy.
I'm sorry.
I was so happy, guys.
Guys...
We cannot close this door!
Door closed.
There's one more door.
There's one more!
Oh, it's on the other side!
God!
I'm sorry, Jack Koons!
I got so excited!
I got too excited.
I don't want to close this door.
Alright...
Okay.
Door closed.
There we go.
How do I close this door?
How do I...
How do I close you?
Oh, there you go.
Guys, I'm scared just standing in the open like this.
How do I... How do I close you?
Oh.
No, I can only climb!
What do you mean?
Okay.
Where do I close?
Did I close?
Oh my god.
Where are you?
Guys, how did I close this door?
The door is stuck!
All I can do is climb!
Okay.
There has to be another closed door.
There has to be.
Closed door.
Did it close?
Oh no.
Guys, please.
The door is actually stuck.
I'm going to release all the doors and I'm going to close it.
Do I give up control of the surface?
Yes.
What does it do?
I gave up control.
What did it do?
Oh!
Yay!
We did it, guys!
We're running!
Guys!
We did it!
The train's running, Dragoon!
Dragoon.
The train's running and it's...
Yay!
How do I close this door?
We did it!
Jaegun, we did it!
Jaegun!
No, I didn't!
No, they didn't fire me!
They said if I would like to give up.
So...
That's different.
I just retired voluntarily, guys.
It's different, guys!
I retired voluntarily!
Chat, I didn't get fired.
I got... I volunteered to retire.
What the fuck?
Who are you?
Why are you in my seat?
I'm gonna press the emergency brake.
Get off my seat!
That's fucking right.
What are you gonna do about it?
Huh?
I'm gonna press all your buttons.
That's fucking right.
I stopped your engine.
Wait, how are you still going?
I'm gonna take the key.
That's fucking right.
What are you gonna do about it?
Wait, why is the train still going?
It's a ghost train!
They put chat block on here!
I'm the co-pilot.
I'm the coach.
You literally...
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
Guys, I'm the co... No, I'm the co-pilot.
Guys, see?
I got my baby chair.
I'm sitting here.
I'm like the baby chair.
Don't piss me off, Dragoons.
I'm gonna turn off the AC.
Guys!
Don't make me angry.
Oh wait, I'm gonna put it on heat.
During the summer.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
Even though I can't control the train anymore, I can still control the temperature.
No AC.
That's right.
You don't deserve AC, Dragoons.
Don't make me...
Turn off your lights too!
Oh, I will turn on the reading light too.
Don't make me do this.
Not the AC.
How could you, you monster?
Are we there yet?
Did we make it to the stop?
Yeah.
What do you mean?
I'm gonna cook myself.
I'm gonna turn on the fucking doors too.
That's fucking right.
Don't make me...
Don't make me stop the train forcefully.
Dragoon, get over here.
I'm gonna pick you up.
And I'm gonna open this door.
Dragoon, you see this door?
You see that door, Dragoon?
Dragoon!
That's fucking right.
Okay, now I don't know how to close this door.
So we're gonna leave it open.
We're gonna leave this door open.
Because I don't know how to close it.
Why is it so far?
Did we pass or stop?
I think we passed or stopped.
There's no way.
Are we...
Are we close?
I can't tell.
I know we're definitely behind schedule.
I know.
I think...
Because it says zero yards.
So I feel like...
Are we behind schedule?
Oh, 10 minute ride.
Look at top left.
Oh!
Holy shit, this is a lot.
I'm fucking out of here.
Oh!
Put me in camera mode.
What?
It's okay.
I can...
I try...
If I try to jump off, it puts me in camera mode.
Are you serious?
Oh shit, there you go.
Goodbye.
Oh.
At least they have a conductor.
Yay!
Wait, I can like walk all the way there?
Oh.
Goodbye train.
I don't think it's gonna stop for me guys.
This is my train now.
What train am I on now?
What the fuck?
Holy shit.
I'm on a new train guys.
Hey!
New dragoons!
Hey guys!
Wow!
Wait, this train has more people.
Than my other train.
How come more of you guys are on this train?
The one I wasn't driving on.
Dragoons.
Why are there more trains?
Why are there more people on this train?
Dragoons!
Huh?
Why are there more passengers?
The other train had less passengers.
This is... this is awkward.
Guys.
Wait, are there people actually...
Guys, there's actually people in first class?
Why do these dragoons...
How come these dragoons...
actually...
actually pay for first class?
Compared to my other train?
Oh no, she found us.
You guys have some explaining to do.
This is going to London.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe you guys didn't trust me.
Chat.
I can't believe none of you guys...
trust me.
I say as I press the emergency brake.
I can't believe it.
Wait, does that have max brake on?
Oh, because I press on the emergency brake.
Wait, when is this train going to stop?
I feel like this train has been going on for a while now too.
Where are you guys stopping at?
London's King Cross?
Next station stop?
Who's that?
Is that a train?
Is that the one I was at?
Oh, that's the stop I was at earlier.
We should be close because like...
I didn't make that much progress.
So we should be back there soon.
Leave me.
Yeah?
Alright guys, we're going back to where we started.
That was fun.
I think I...
I think I like...
I definitely stretched out the train meta.
I didn't...
We played...
We played three different train games today.
It was definitely...
It was pretty fun.
I think it's better letting the AI drive the train than letting me drive.
We got three train games in a row, chat.
Is that crazy?
We actually played three train games.
I spent like at least $80 on just train games today.
Which is like more than like...
Which is usually a lot more money that I usually spend on like...
on one stream.
So...
It's still cheaper than...
Oh, you're right!
It is cheaper than one singular train...
Like IRL train ticket.
Or like IRL train...
Like those train collectors.
Are we stopping?
Are we stopping soon?
Oh my god, okay.
Are we stopping?
Where is it?
Where's the stop?
Is that London?
Is that London's King Cross?
Why are we slowing down?
Ma'am, why are you slowing down?
That's not the stop.
That doesn't look like the stop.
I hope the other...
I hope the other train is almost there.
I hope...
I hope the other train is almost at its destination.
Safely pulling in?
What's that?
I don't understand that.
I don't understand that sentence.
What do you mean safely pulling in?
This feels way too slow.
She's following the rules?
Rules?
What?
What do you mean rules?
Alright, let's turn on the high fan.
And then we're going to turn on...
We're going to make sure you guys are at a good temperature.
Oh, there it is!
There's London!
Cross!
There it is!
London King's Cross!
We made it, guys!
Oh my god!
We made it!
Guys, welcome back!
Oh my god, chat!
We fucking made it!
Wait, is this not the destination?
Oh...
Wait, is this not London's King's Cross?
Wait, why did that guy not stop?
Wait, that train didn't stop, guys.
Guys...
Don't think this is London's King's Cross.
Oh my god!
No, it is!
Wait...
Guys, I don't...
Guys, I don't think that was London's...
Guess I went to the...
Guys, I went to the wrong area.
It's okay, I just got five...
Wait, what?
How do I leave?
How do I...
How did all of you guys leave?
Oh, this is when you guys want to board to a new area.
Oh, I see.
Where are we going?
Guys, I think...
I don't think I went to London.
King's Cross.
Guys...
I don't think that...
Guys, I can't...
How do I get out?
Oh, there it is!
There it is!
Oh my god!
No!
My soul is tied to the train!
Oh no, JK.
JK, I...
JK, I could open the door.
Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
No, I'm stuck in the train I mentioned.
No!
I'm stuck in the train I mentioned!
My soul can't leave!
No!
I'm so...
I'm stuck here forever.
I can't believe it.
I'm stuck here forever!
I was a ghost all along!
That was a good time to call it.
Alright.
I think that was a good $80.
Well spent.
Solaris, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That laugh is infectious.
I'm glad you...
I hope you guys had fun with all the train games that we had today.
Chat, we played a lot of train games today.
We streamed a lot longer than I expected today.
Because I had a lot of fun just playing random train games with all of you.
But yeah!
I'm going to call it here, everybody.
And rest now.
For those who don't know, My YouTube's figure is out!
So please check it out!
And support me.
Support me and build up your Doki shrine there.
Apparently a lot of orders have been shipped out.
Except for the bundles for the merch store.
We do have a lot of the individual items have shipped out.
So you might have received an email about it.
If you ordered the individual items in the merch store, That's not like the bundles and stuff.
You should receive an email.
If you didn't receive an email yet, Maybe in a couple of weeks, You might get the email.
But yeah!
Oh my god!
There's so many things going on behind the scenes right now.
I feel like every day is like...
Every day is like...
Uh...
There's so much work behind the scenes.
But...
There's so many exciting things coming in the future.
And it's like, it's crazy.
Thank you guys for all that support, Dragalones.
Almost every day is like...
A certain work day.
So, but I've been having a lot of fun.
I've been having a lot of fun hanging out with you guys too.
And just like doing random shit like today.
We're just...
We're just playing random games and stuff.
But yeah guys, it's always a great time.
As always, I'm gonna head out now.
I'm gonna relax.
And chill.
Well, not really relax because I have a lot of work behind the scenes.
But as always everybody...
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me...
Head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.